wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn the secret to Building Wealth on
shorter timelines how to find good
Investments why you need to believe in
what you do and how to master sales and
marketing skills this episode is all
about making smart moves that set you up
for Success
enjoy hello and welcome back for episode
five of wealth breakthroughs I'm Patrick
gentempo and it's great to have you with
us in this episode we'll hear from three
masters of their craft and we'll begin
with an absolute wealth breakthroughs
icon George Gilder handed president
Reagan the first microchip Reagan ever
saw he also predicted the smartphone the
rise of streaming companies like Netflix
and today he'll share with you what
could be his boldest most earthshaking
prediction in decades in short and I
don't think I'm giving too much away the
old internet is dead what replaces it
well as George is about to show you will
create enormous wealth breakthroughs for
those who act
fast
[Music]
George you have such a stored career I
feel like we could do an entire docy
series just on you so we'll try to
encapsulate maybe if we can just talk
about your background and experience
maybe the highlights uh that got you
doing what you're doing today well I've
been a writer written 20 bucks I've
became a Ronald Reagan's most quoted
living author with wealth and poverty
which was a book that
reformulated the case for capitalism and
the supply side Vision MH after uh
wealth and poverty sold millions of
copies around the world with the number
one book in France for six months and
had samz dot editions in Russia and
China I figured I'd
covered economics and plunged into
technology and I saw that the microchip
was the most important invention of this
era and I've devoted my life to learning
the physics of
microchips I went to calch not as a
student but as a visitor and Inquirer
and and a follower of Carver me the
great
microchip philosopher of Caltech who
both researched and named Moore's Law
which is sort of the law that has
governed the whole evolution of
microchips and Computing ever since the
doubling of computer power every year
right so I've predicted in 1990 that the
key computer of the future would be as
portable as your watch as personal as
your wallet it would recognize
speech it would navigate streets it
would collect your news and your mail
maybe your
paycheck might not do
windows I did that for a Microsoft
audience but it would but it would do
doors open doors to your future and I've
become known as uh technology
futurist um and but I began writing
about sex back in my youth I I became
Pig of the year that was that's my
proudest ACH the male chauvinist Pig of
the year yeah the National Organization
of Women and Time Magazine they all
piled in and said I was Pig of the year
and so my family gave me a little Golden
Pig they I retired I retired the trophy
uh because I had so much fun being Pig
of the year that that uh none of the or
no one ever Awards any pigs of the Year
anymore I was I retired it so so I'm the
reigning Pig of the Year forever forever
so you went to Harvard some years ago
what did you study did you think you'd
be doing I was no I flunked out of
Harvard I went into the Marine Corps
came back I finished at Harvard my tutor
was Henry
Kissinger um and I really
studied
strategy and U I didn't do well at all I
can't I can't really focus on more than
one thing at a time and Harvard has the
idea you're supposed to be taking five
or six courses and uh I I I couldn't do
it I ran track I did write a major paper
though uh on quantitative and
qualitative arms races which uh I showed
everybody wanted to ban nuclear weapons
or ban this or that and uh I pointed out
that uh
technological arms races favor free
people and invent an invention
quantitative arms races which is what
happens if you ban all uh technological
progress MH means mobilizing more and
more of the resources and people of the
country and
and really impoverishing the country to
some
climactic outcome of war or an invasion
or so I felt that qualitative arms races
competing in human creativity and
invention was a positive thing and that
uh quantitative arms races is what you
had to fear where pretty soon you have
Garrison States facing off against each
other with nothing to do but fight so I
really was proud of that paper and it
really foreshadowed all the rest of my
career which has been focusing on
technological creativity so I think even
back then uh you know it was about tech
because that's really a technological
Insight when you're looking at
qualitative versus quantitative arms
races right and do you see technology as
as this kind of inevitability as far far
as you there's no way to really try to
harness or control it it's it's it's on
no I don't see it as an inevitability so
how do you see that it's human it's a
product of human creativity and and
humans can forget uh I like the story of
uh when I was used to write about sex
Margaret I used to like Margaret me's
story about the anthrop
Anthropologist about
the mar Warriors of the Andaman Islands
or one of those islands of Polynesian
tribes that were learned how to make
these wonderful kayaks that allowed them
to rule all the Seas and bring in huge
harvests of fish and be really the
dominant force and at some point they
forgot how to make their kayaks and when
Margaret me visited them they were sort
of looking these former Warriors looking
for were LLY out at the water and uh in
the process of going extinct because
they
forgot uh their key mission in the world
and the key secret of their survival and
success and we we're we're doing that
now we're we're in we're perfectly
possible to forego technology there've
been Dark Ages throughout the history of
the human race and and much most of the
Ages were dark to tell the truth it
wasn't until amazing burst of Luminosity
at the time of the Industrial
Revolution that the human race really
learned how to create wealth in an
enduring and and uh successful way so no
uh technology is not inevitable it is
something that has to be created and uh
that requires free societies and I was
just about to say so the the threat
would be I'm assuming based on what
you're saying that you're a big fan of
technology and what it's going to do to
uh for Humanity well it's what we do
yeah I mean it's what it does for
Humanity is is part of it but but it's
human beings are made to be creative in
the image of their creator and that's
the source of all these techn IES the
great sort of heresy of of the
Contemporary era is the idea that that
everything is sort of random and happens
inevitably as a result of uh of some
evolutionary principle that's never been
uh fully expounded or explained and it's
an idea of a random
Universe uh creating us and when
scientists recognized that a random
Universe would not create the complexity
of human life they then uh imagined
infinite numbers of random universes and
one of them just as a matter of accident
would produce us and naturally we're the
ones who are testifying so we're in the
universe that produced us and I think
this whole random model is
is is quite obtuse and and it uh doesn't
explain everything anything but it does
but it is
demoralizing and it
diminishes all our achievements and it
diminishes technology and I think it's
it's wrong I couldn't agree with you
more on that and I think it's almost a
cop out you know they don't want to face
certain uh obvious realities in order to
draw those types of conclusions so now
and you've written extensively on
economics uh and supply side economics I
think you mentioned already uh and the
the virtue of that um when we look at
the principles of economics and then the
generation of wealth and then bring it
down to the individual personal wealth
uh do you think that the general
principles have have changed you know
from the let's call it maybe the pre-
technological era as far as today's
technology and now are they're the same
it's just technology is the natural
expression of them I think technology is
always all errors are technological
errors but humans without tools are
really impotent to expand or survive or
anything
so humans creating
tools has been the theme of of human
history and fate and so so I I I don't
think we're in a technolog olcal era
today while we were not in a
technological era 100 years ago or 200
years ago we the phase though of
economic growth and progress did begin
with the Industrial Revolution yes and
uh really in the 17th 18th century and
uh that really was
the beginning of it and that's the era
we're still in launched really by is
Newton who both defined physics and
launched the gold standard which really
was the foundation of the British Empire
I mean how did I didn't know Newton did
that was Master of the men for 35 years
all the histories of Newton say Newton
was a brilliant physicist wrote
principia and transformed our
understanding of gravity and the
universe and and uh then
retired into the ccure at the mint and U
worked on Alchemy and a sort of
irrational religious Obsession and they
just completely misunderstood Newton's
career I mean when he became Master of
the men he established essentially
establish the gold standard and in order
to do that he had to prove that gold was
fundamental and ultimate ultimate that
you couldn't make gold out of uh
inferior cheaper elements right and
that's what all he was hacking gold that
just as as people try to hack the
Bitcoin blockchain or the ethereum
blockchain or whatever or Bitcoin Newton
was hacking gold and and uh by
absolutely establishing that you could
not make gold P out a ladder some
inferior element as people were
speculating could be done he uh
established the gold standard and
establishing the gold standard he
enabled the British Empire Britain was a
was not the dominant Financial power of
the world Amsterdam was and after Newton
established the gold standard in England
um it's a great Saga Britain became the
world's power the Sun never sat on the
British Empire and this in the city in
London was the center of World Finance
for 200 years I mean it was just an
amazing feat of intellect and I I'd like
to think Newton pretty much informed the
Industrial Revolution with his physics
and the economical
and political revolution with the gold
standard so a single Global money wow so
this is interesting uh actually
fascinating for me looking at uh you
know how principles you know that can
seem somewhat abstract can be applied to
you know human uh society and and
economics and politics and how they can
shift things in in either really good
direction or really bad Direction
depending on which principles you choose
right uh but what's fascinating to me
and what you brought up I'd love to get
your views on is cryptocurrency so you
talked about okay you talk you Bitcoin
ethereum Etc what is your view on
cryptocurrency do you see it as a good
thing do you see it something that's
going to emerge and continue to to grow
or do you see it as something that's
going to pass well I think it's the most
important technology of our era and uh
it's importance that addresses at one
time with one
essential uh theme of Discovery and
development the two great crises of the
world economy and one is the utter
collapse of Internet Security you know
we had a billion breaches of private
data last year a billion it's up to
three billion this year on track for
three billion this year Internet
Security doesn't work because it's a
patched on afterwards and um the
internet's growing faster than uh
security industry can address it you
know as it's governed by meta's law
which is that uh the value of a network
Grows by the square essentially of the
number of uh entities connected to it
and uh the number of entities connecting
to the internet is is growing
exponentially with the internet of
things and so so the attack surface for
hackers uh is growing
explosively and the various security uh
companies you know are address each uh
attack with a single patch that uh
resolves a single problem aat threat
it's a cat and mouse game where the uh
the mice
are multiplying exponentially and the
cats are growing additively and the
result is uh the more money we spend on
Internet
Security uh the more breaches we get the
more hacks succeed so it's just it's a
tremendous failure and uh because of
this it because the internet was not
founded with any idea of being a
platform for transactions and and uh
really uh vital activities of this sort
it was a Communications medium solely
it's a giant copying machine so this is
a crisis you can tell how much of a
crisis it is that we're now par so
paranoid we won't even let routers from
China into our Network you that Huawei
routers are being banned and they don't
that's not enough they now are Banning
us from selling chips to ruwei or any of
these other Chinese technology companies
we're banishing chips to all their face
recognition companies and this is uh
machine learning this is the heart of
technological progress but we're in this
absurd position of trying to block out
of foreign technology from the United
States and preserve a lead that we no
longer have and this is all because of
the breakdown in Internet Security the
remedy for it is to banish the paranoia
to to actually create a new internet
architecture that solves this problem
and that's the blockchain the blockchain
is a new architecture for the internet
that creates a secure and mutable
timestamped uh ground state on which you
can build all the applications you want
and have uh Dependable outcomes and not
this current kind of porous pyramid
where all the money and power Rises to
the top where then it gets hacked so
does the blockchain democ the blockchain
solves that problem pretty much if you
really uh fulfill the blockchain
agenda and uh the cryptocosm as I call
it resolves that problem but the other
great problem of the world economy is
what I call a scandal of money we've
been talking about Newton and the
British Empire and the gold as a single
Universal money and now we have the
alternative to the gold
standard is uh floating
currencies and we now have $5.1 trillion
dollar a day of floating currencies
that's 25 times roughly all Global GDP
wow it's 73 times all trade in goods and
services and it doesn't even stop trade
Wars and uh constant monetary Maneuvers
and minations and suspicions and charges
and counter charges
and and uh this is just a complete
failure floating currencies it was
Milton fredman's dream and it was a
failure as Milton himself began to
recognize in his in his last years and
cryptocurrencies are the solution to
that they can prod what
Satoshi the originator of Bitcoin
imagined was that he was creating a new
gold m and uh and so here one one great
technological movement addresses both
the central problems of the world
economy the collapse of Internet
Security and the collapse of money and
trade Wars and mercantilism you know I
never put those two things together but
it it's interesting because uh you know
looking at blockchain as being the
solution Internet Security and also
having a currency that is you know now
not a floating currency as you described
it uh I didn't see that we're getting
two for one on that um but really
fascinating do you think uh that there's
going to be um you see because you have
so many now so many different
cryptocurrencies that are being offered
is it kind of the Wild Wild West is that
going to thin out and you're going to
have a couple of survivors so what do
you think the future holds there well
the resolution on u a few uh crypto
platforms that can actually sustain
these thousand
of um applications that are being
developed for them is the great
challenge of of this immediate period
Bitcoin and ethereum have had
fundamental flaws in their concept that
have um not stopped them from being
vastly important initiatives and
Innovations but have impaired their
ability to really function as platform
forms for what ultimately will be
millions of
applications right and their ethereum
had a great success in iOS it's the
rc20 token really could handle icos and
uh the great failure of the US economy
for the last 20 years or so has been the
collapse of initial public offerings 90%
drop in the number of initial public
offerings
in the recent years we've had these
giant offerings of
unicorns but they aren't really like uh
the Ecology of
startups that uh really built Silicon
Valley and and built the internet and
all the companies on the internet and so
we had a 90% drop in an initial public
offerings we 50% shrinkage and the
number of uh compan companies listed
publicly on our stock markets and it
really was a a crisis yeah and vitalic
buan of ethereum in invented not just a
a new blockchain and a new platform a
new Computing language to program smart
contracts on these on this new platform
and new money called ether and a new
source of value called gas and then
accomplished or raise some 20 billion
dollar for uh thousands of of new crypto
startups and a lot of them have failed
but uh this was just a tremendous feat
and it proved that this technology
actually worked I mean raising close to
$25 billion now is nothing
for uh an array of startups that uh
otherwise couldn't raise money was a
tremendous accomplishment and Bitcoin as
a emergency asset and speculative vessel
and um alternative currency for ven
Venezuela and Zimbabwe and Greece and
countries that whose money completely
disintegrates it has been great success
in its way but now they got thousands
and thousands of applications and smart
contracts operating on the blockchain
itself integrated with the blockchain
just completely
congest um ethereum and the solutions
that they're developing mainly sharding
and dynamic sharding which is breaking
up the blockchain into Smither and and
reassembling them and I I I believe is
probably not a viable solution so so
here we have Bitcoin and with its silly
cap at 20 million units thus assuring
that it can't really be a money that you
can use and uh you have uh for
transactions and and expanding economy
and and you have ethereum with this
blockchain that can't really handle the
demand at all so we but the
entrepreneurs see this huge opportunity
and there are uh hundreds of new
projects and uh many of them are very
promising very ingenious have surmounted
the key problems I believe that Bitcoin
and ethereum face
and U in the next year we're going to
see him and it's going to be an exciting
time to be alive in America or whatever
and in the world because it really is a
world movement it's it's not a that's
right it's it doesn't know a
governmental bounds but now talk to me
as an individual investor uh So based on
your perspectives uh as you just laid
them out uh should I be investing in
Bitcoin ethereum or should I be waiting
for the newer techn te ologies to emerge
well certainly betting on I mean
bitcoin's become a speculative thing and
Traders trade Bitcoin now and Bitcoin
May well find its Niche and and be a a
good investment even now uh it uh I just
don't think it's the solution to the
World Monetary problem right and that's
what
Satoshi uh aimed to achieve
and uh we need a a new Satoshi Craig
Wright was and his ally was
probably
Satoshi and uh he's kind of an
obsessive
genius but uh it doesn't seem that he's
going to be able to grasp the real
challenge of creating a global money
he's too infatuated with the Bitcoin
model as that stands and and lots of
people are I mean people who invest in
Bitcoin imagine that having a cap of 21
million units is somehow the secret to
their unbounded future of speculative
success and and wealth and uh I think it
Dooms Bitcoin to failure so so I think
it's all it it
may it leads to immediate
volatility and it leads to this dream
that you have a resource that's
inexorably scarce and thus infinitely
valuable but uh I think that is um a
great mistake the Bitcoin flaw as I call
it in my book life after Google which is
my explanation of the blockchain and the
future and in that I the last chapter is
called the Bitcoin flaw and I think
think Bitcoin is not the final solution
to the
blockchain uh promise so in essence for
speculative train trading some money
could be made there but you're you're
not seeing that this is the a future
that's going to unfold but the
cryptocosm is all these companies
together are generating not only the new
internet platform and system but also uh
ultimately hundreds of thousands of
applications for a new
secure internet that actually can
accommodate
transactions and and uh the blockchain
has to be used for only for critical
path data you know the for crucial
identities and private keys and actual
transactional records and ledgers but to
have it also an actual processing plat
form and um and a memory storage arena
is just a mistake it's making the
blockchain do things that it's not not
optimal to do so if I were let's say a
young man coming out of college and I
came to you and I
said Mr Gilder I would have tried to get
you out of college first earlier like
I'm I'm part of the
1517 fund which is Peter Teal's program
for luring people away from these
ludicrous anti-education
institutions that are U polluting our
landscape or let's say I'm in college
and you lure actual landscape so I lured
you out of college this is perfect so
now you've lured me out of college
saying don't waste your time it's going
to actually hurt you not help you and
now I so I come to you and say I'm I I
would like to uh create wealth in my
life personal wealth what advice would
you give me buan was the one of the key
teal fellows who got lured out of
college to go to work and actually learn
something in the world and U buin
created ethereum and and I'm an enormous
admirer of him and of ethereum although
I do believe that it it's not the final
solution for the but I I think this is
the new frontier is uh uh creating a new
internet and a new Global monetary
system and there are trillions of
dollars worth of opportunity in that uh
and that dollars represented not as a
speculative unit but as a measuring
stick that's what money is money is not
wealth in itself and if you just pursue
money in itself you probably won't uh
become wealthy because uh wealth wealth
is actually
knowledge and you can know that wealth
is knowledge because the Neanderthal in
his cave as Thomas Soul wrote long ago
had all the na all the material
resources we have today every atom and
molecule of resources we have today was
available to the Neanderthal in his cave
the difference between our age and the
Stone Age age is entirely the growth of
knowledge wealth is knowledge and if
wealth is
knowledge what's economic
growth knowledge growth knowledge growth
which is learning right so now just told
you just pulled me out of college though
I pulled you out of college so you can
start learning in college they're
indoctrinating which is a completely
anti- learning uh process they have this
ludicrous climate change cult that has
completely captivated my institution
Harvard is Raising hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars as the new
president of Harvard declares to make
all the departments in the University
devoted to a sustainability and climate
change it's an absolute Mania and it's
it's totally wrong and stupid uh there's
nothing in the climate that's any
different today to there less CO2 in the
atmosphere than there was when the dinos
hundreds of times less when the
dinosaurs cavorted across the planet I
mean it's just it's just the it's a
totally
flawed hypothesis and theory and it's
been proven wrong and uh and yet uh all
our colleges want to dismantle our
economy in order to make various
feckless
sacrifices uh to supposedly appease this
this Malik of climate that uh they
believe faces them I mean it's very like
those Warriors in the Polynesian Islands
that Margaret me saw uh forgetting the
actual sources of their wealth which is
moving ahead not uh going backwards into
windmills that's the ultimate K K quick
sotic
Pursuit uh you know replacing good
energy sources with bad energy sources
uh that waste the surface of the planet
which is which is a scarce resource
about the only scarce resources is the
surface of the planet and to cover it
with windmills and and druidical Sun
henges as I call these
solar installations is just totally a AC
of
of cultural suicide and and our
universities are utterly devoted to it
so uh so forget them they're they're
they're retreating to the sun age
they're
Druids so this this is something that I
find a phenomenal distinction something
indoctrination versus education so now
okay okay now now I say wow okay I see
the distinction I don't want to go into
an indoctrination process so how do I go
get myself educated what can I do to
educate myself that puts me on the path
so I can create wealth in my life well
there's just wonderful online
educational programs now you can uh
Clayton Christensen believes that the
Clayton Christensen was the my partner
in an earlier Venture and he's a
wonderful man who invented disrupt
disruptive technology the whole concept
of disruption originated with Clayton
Christensen and uh he believes that the
American University establishment he's a
professor at the Harvard Business School
so he has a close view of the situation
is just open to vast disruption into the
com future period just uh education is
just going to be drastically cheaper and
more efficient and more more effective
and more productive than it is today
where um a kind of priesthood of
Professor uh rules and uh collects uh
huge bounties and
indoctrinates the students into a kind
of economic impedence so so let's say
I'm not an unusual genius that's going
to write the next blockchain code and
deploy it well who knows
uh studying all those subjects is very
mathematics is still the language of
science it doesn't answer all questions
but it's a vital tool for everybody to
learn and uh all the Sciences all are to
the extent they don't get infatuated
with some religious cult or um
stultified
by uh some
spurious political IAL campaign uh The
Sciences are are valuable to study and
you they're The crucial tools uh they
give you ways to invent new things they
don't tell you what to invent and uh
that's a matter of philosophy and and
religion and aspiration and all with
imagination uh that these are what make
the human mind the ultimate kind of
value in our in the
universe you're writing right now uh the
daily prophecy yeah and uh so and you've
been doing this for a while I guess uh
that every single day you're putting out
a well not on weekends I've now learned
for the first time in my life I've
learned that weekends are different from
weekdays it never knew it before but I
only have to do the prophecy on the five
weekday and uh so and what kind of
things are you writing about now I'm
writing about I'm devoting a lot of time
to showing that this really is the
greatest economic and technological era
in the history of the human race that we
are we're not in a period of stagnation
and failure we're in a period of
efflorescent creativity across the world
economy that economists and uh
government officials totally mismeasure
in all their economic data in the
scandal of money I developed the idea of
money as
time money is a measuring stick it's
like a clock a second or a meter or
a Candela or a degree Kelvin or a
kilogram or any of those measuring
sticks that that uh are administered in
Paris and system international they take
all the key measuring sticks that make
possible International Commerce of the
second is the same in Paris as it is in
quala lumur and in Antarctica the second
and studying all these measuring sticks
I discovered they all ultimately are
anchored in time if you're going to get
a physical constant that um underlies a
a crucial measuring stick uh it all
resolves on the second which is uh
measured by uh the cycles of the
radioactive emissions of cesium a
particular element but all the various
measuring sticks have some physical
constant involved in them and when I
scrutinize them from the kilogram to the
meter to the Ampere they all have a
frequency involved in them and if and a
frequency is ultimately based on Hertz
you know the cycles per second so what I
really discovered is all these measuring
sticks are ultimately rooted in
time and uh and it's these measuring
sticks that make it possible to design a
microchip in Palo Alto and have it
developed into a system and tele and and
um made into a actual device and silicon
and taipe and Taiwan and put on a
circuit board in shenzen and China and
then marketed in copertino this is the
centilating supply chain that is
underlies our Global wealth and we're
currently trying to disrupt in Every
Which Way but it's the source of our
wealth and the promise of our future
anyway uh to do to do this
globalis technological system the second
and the nanc and the Pico second and the
nanometer and the Micron and the meter
and the Ampere they have to be the same
all over the world and uh just as
important to this vast
International Endeavor as
measuring Nan nanometers of silicon is
money because money is the way you
evaluate all these different all your
different options you PRI prioritize you
trade off one thing and another money is
absolutely a critical measuring stick of
wealth it's not wealth in itself it's a
measuring stick and so rooted in time
and it's rooted in time like all the
rest time is what remains scarce when
everything else grows abundant when
everything else grows abundant under
capitalism time is what remains scarce
well in the last few months I've come to
know Gail
py and Marian tupy who together are um
engaged in a great effort to take this
time concept of money and translate it
into time prices for all the goods and
services of the world and these time
prices measure the value of anything by
the number of hours that you have to
work to earn the money to buy it that's
what you really spend when you go to the
store it's the hours of work you had to
perform to get the money to buy it
changed that where you you become you
can produce more and more in less and
less time y That's right so the time
prices this is how p tupy and pulie and
tupy have however you want to they're a
team but U I've been working with Gail
pulley a lot who's a professor at
Brigham Young and they've proven that uh
they my proposition about wealth being
knowledge and my proposition that uh
time is
money they they're proving it and
they've shown that uh since
1980 prices have dropped
72% all around the all the major
Commodities everything all the 50 things
most needed to sustain human life
relative to the time of the consumer
relative to the time it takes to earn
the money to buy them wow in other words
if if you want a filet of
salmon uh you had to spend only 14% as
much time to uh buy it today as you did
when you in in 1980 which uh not so long
ago
uh if you want to buy a Thanksgiving
dinner the Farm Bureau does a analysis
of Thanksgiving dinner 16 for 10
Thanksgiving uh uh 16 lb turkey a gallon
of milk uh cranberries sweet whatever
right and uh the Farm Bureau judging by
the Consumer Price Index CPI imagines
that a Thanksgiving dinner costs no more
today than it did in 1986 when they
started calculating the numbers and
they're very proud of that but the fact
is if you're a blue collar worker in
America in 1980 you spent 32
minutes of work to buy your Thanksgiving
dinner one tenth of that offering today
how long do you think you got to work a
blue collar worker yeah uh uh probably
half that nine minutes yeah so not half
that a third that about a third less
than a third and um that shows wealth is
increasing then vastly yeah and it shows
that the CPI is totally wrong uh the the
GDP deflator is totally wrong all those
purchasing power parody guesses between
currencies are mostly a model the way to
measure values is time prices how long
it takes takes to work to buy anything
and by that measure we can we're in a
tremendous boom of abundance today
there's no decline in the only things
that are going up in price are worthless
things like like a college education a
college degree that they've got people
fetishizing uh but uh and Medical Care
is improving hugely you you sure surely
wouldn't choose choose the medical care
of 19 19 7 over today but the pricing of
Medical Care is absolutely chaotic and
stupid because of government
intervention as an ran would have told
you back then
yes
soed but uh but time prices are
absolutely a fabulous invention these
Gail pulley and Maran tupy um one from
St an St Andrew in Scotland that's tupi
and pulley from uh briam young and
Hawaii have have are doing a revolution
and they're they're showing that all all
the government data is wrong and all are
understanding of like um negative
interest rates are you interested in
negative interest rates yeah but two
quick questions on that before you leave
it number one so is in essence
redistribution of wealth is
redistribution of time that's right yeah
of of of the people who prod it's which
is very interesting I find that
fascinating uh the second question is
with AI and and you can show by the way
that uh great Improvement in equality by
using time prices you show that this is
an era not of wildly increasing
inequality but of vastly increasing
equality but when they're creating
floating currency isn't that basically
saying hey we're making up we're
creating time here that doesn't exist
yeah we're manipula we're it's the
central banks of the world are in a vast
futile um Rebellion Against Time Time is
what every economic decision is governed
by time but that's a denial of reality
isn't it that's a denial of reality and
so we have a massive Global denial of
reality that's preventing us from even
seeing what's going on in the world so
it's got to a reckoning at some point
there's a reckoning which something to
talk about but the the second thing is
does technologically with uh Robotics
and AI is going to get to a point where
almost it takes almost no time to
produce a lot of this stuff energy food
Etc there's an exaggeration of Robotics
and AI Robotics and AI create
jobs they don't destroy jobs people have
to create the robots people have to
create create the robotics they collect
the data they Define the data they just
this this whole illusion uh that because
a Robotics and AI can win a Chess
Championship or a go game against the
world human Champion that this means
somehow that they have humanlike metal
Powers they it's as Jack maah the head
of Alibaba uh said the other that human
beings chasing machines and doing
deterministic mathematics that is always
comes out the same answer is like human
beings trying to race a car it's just
silly uh what a computer does has
nothing to do with what a brain does
computers do
deterministic calculations that is the
outcome is always the same it's uh it's
deterministic like a set of chess moves
or go moves you the move always has the
same result so it's not creative it's
it's not creative right it's not even
informative yeah information is entropy
as Shannon showed Claude Shannon who
invented information Theory who invented
the bit and the bite as units of
information right and information is
unexpected bits information is surprisal
it's unexpected outcomes and if your
machine starts having unexpected
outcomes it's probably broken it's the
essence of computation is deterministic
outcomes that and the human mind is has
imagination it does
counterfactuals it does Futures that
won't happen it invents things it's it
uh combines different categories it's
complex beyond the whole internet um I
mean one of my U interests is the
connectome studies you know have you
heard of the connectome the connectome
is all the connections that uh make up a
network is called a
connect and uh for the last 10 years or
so the government has financed this huge
study uh of all the connections in the
human brain and um but there's
inexplicable emerging properties that
come from that all all the connections
I've been studying a connectome of the
internet for a long time I've wrote Tel
aosm and microcosm and these books about
the internet technology life after
Google and and um all all the
connections all across the global
internet uh can be uh stored in about
one a few
zettabytes of information that's 10 to
the 21 a zetabyte that's the connectome
of the internet the human
brain has uh all the dendrites and all
axons and of the human brain synapses
also come to a
or two wow so the one human brain has
the complexity of the entire Global
Internet the entire Global Internet
takes gws of power to run the human
brain runs on 10 to 12
watts and it's in other words the one
human brain is billions of times more
efficient than the entire global
internet and all the memory connected to
the global internet adds up to a zabte
or so there's just a complete delusion
and Silicon Valley about uh the powers
of computers compared to the powers of
human brains and and they just uh you
can confine the computer to a specific
purpose and and it can do anything it's
you program it and it can do anything
that's determinist
uh it's not making decisions and
judgments really unless you
pre-specify uh the target sequences or
whatever that by which you will make the
Judgment but the idea that that it's
that what a computer does it's is
anything but a collection of onoff which
is totally dumb is is delusional and and
Silicon Valley is currently infatuated
with this this delusion and it's
resulted in this silly fear that that
technology destroys jobs when when the
our whole experience from the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution is the more
tools you have you don't hire somebody
because they're unproductive right right
computers make people more productive AI
makes people more productive and thus
more
employable and better jobs and jobs that
are more perfectly adapted all the time
to the
particular potentialities of our amazing
human Minds so you mentioned earlier
negative interest rates and you want to
go back to talk about that well just
it's it's just interesting that all the
financial press everywhere the all the
heads of the international monetary fund
the World Bank all the leading
professors of the world from
uh Harvard uh Larry Summers Ken rogoff
everybody is concerned with negative
interest rates and at conferences they
make no sense at all that negative
interest rates are contrary to all
economics you can't have them time is
going in the opposite direction that you
it can't be right and in fact it isn't
right these rates are not even remotely
negative we as tupi and Puli have
documented we're actually in a period
where prices are dropping 3.6% a year
where uh where new things are being
invented all the time the future is far
uh richer than the present in
expectation and so our real interest
rates are calculated by subtracting
inflation from the nominal interest rate
from the interest rate we we see and if
uh what's actually happening is prices
are dropping 3.6% a year based on time
based on time which is the real that's
the that's the reality all this money
stuff is is the silly governments and
central banks trying to combat the
passage of time but time prices our
interest rates are perfectly reasonable
they're a plus
3.6% which is uh typical for the last
several hundred years and and there's no
there's nothing unusual about it except
that the money's all been scrambled by
central banks but the actual interest
rates in real terms are 3.6% which are
perfectly normal and and in fact reflect
a tremendous increase of global
abundance as a result of um fabulous
creativity led by America but
increasingly a world technology we're no
longer dominant in technology we're
we're the leader but as Bill Joy says
Bill Joy was the founder of sun
co-founder of sun Microsystems and he
says the key thing to understand in
business is this is all the smartest
people never work for you and uh that's
what Americans have to understand about
the world economy the smartest people do
not all uh work for us and the leading
country actually in World technology is
Israel and probably uh China is second
now it's it's a hard thing for Americans
to recognize but and China will be way
ahead if we continue trying to uh
conduct trade Wars as a way to and band
of uh technology exchange and some
paranoid Siege so we don't have negative
interest rates we don't have inflation
you know all these central banks have
this inflation Target why the heck do we
want to debauch the money at 2% every
year but the fact is they aren't coming
close to meeting this where this is a a
period when prices are dropping
massively so giving these variables now
where you talk about technology
increased abundance and and wealth as
far as what how much units of time it
takes to buy a loaf of bread yeah and
now we look at this stock market where
some people are saying it's overinflated
there's going to be a massive correction
but you're seeing great wealth and
abundance you know accelerating at this
point so should I be concerned yeah
should I be concerned if I'm in this in
this market market right now uh that
it's going to correct or do I feel like
it's going to keep expanding I think the
whole pursuit of
markets of stuck Market the stock market
is an effect of the stultification of
investment in the United States by the
Securities and Exchange Commission they
just their rule is that you can't invest
in anything you know
about and uh if knowledge is wealth
it totally thwarts the investment
process they've intimidated all analysts
from actually investigating companies if
if if you find out any inform inside
information you may well be a Croc it's
it's the stupidest thing I've ever seen
in my life the insider trading rules
mean you can't invest in anything you
know about you have to you have to take
these macro numbers I call it
macroman and and and most of the trading
now is uh has moved to computers because
the SEC has not yet indicted a computer
but it hasn't figured out an appropriate
punishment to inflict on a cray a
supercomputer or whatever so we have
this strange divorce uh between the
financial world and the actual world of
human progress and it it's it's creating
huge confusion it's certainly slowing
World economic growth which has been
counteracted by the momentum of of
technological creativity and it's but
it's it's it's a really strange
situation because the stock market is
just it's constantly shrinking because
of this all
successful investment is insider trading
it's either luck or it's insider trading
wow and all that venture capitalist
there's a complete bik foration of
returns that they either go to venture
capitalists who never invest in anything
unless they have intimate knowledge of
all the inside the Tails right or big
conglomerates and the conglomerates
never buy a new company unless they have
intimate knowledge of all the inside
details so those two ends they're legal
Insider Traders and in the stock market
80% of the trading now is companies
buying their own shares that's by
definition inside trading so all the
trading that actually makes a difference
is inside trading only these poor saps
on the
outside are uh are prohibited from
investing in anything they know about
and so they're prohibited from getting
we Wealthy by the SEC attempting to
protect them from exploitation by evil
Brokers and investor I I don't know what
they're about but it's a terrible
mistake you know the SEC is just
squelching
another Ico you know I told you about
Ban's tremendous success and launching a
whole bunch of iOS a lot of them failed
most of them failed like that's way
investment go
but now the SEC is trying to stop icos
they've stopped IPOs and IPOs are only
these exotic unicorn transactions at the
top of the market that that have little
relevance to the average investor
they've essentially stifled you iOS now
they're on on the road stifling iOS they
just stifled the biggest ice most
promising crypto company has just been
squelched by the by the SEC so
regulation basically you know free
market capitalists would say yeah that
regulation is is impeding progress
impeding the production of wealth in the
name of trying to protect citizenry as
compared to let them be responsible for
their own action that's right it's not
that that you don't that you don't need
law you need a predictable low entropy
carrier of Law and tradition and moral
codes and all these things in order to
have a creative capitalist economy but
but the administrative state with all
these predetermined outcomes all across
the economy is a a maze of rules that
actually is creates Anarchy so let me
ask is it then wiser to go because now
they have these new like crowdability
where you can now invest in private
companies uh you know uh it's like
they're pre-ipo perhaps this makes F the
crowdfunding makes perfect sense except
they botch that too how because they
don't let the companies that run these
crowdfunding programs have shares in the
companies that they launch so so in
other words you got their incentive is
to have as many companies as possible
and not care about whether any any of
them have actually valid business plans
and so it's this stupid idea that uh
that if you know about a company you're
going to you have a special Advantage if
you don't have a special Advantage
forget it yeah index funds are are which
now dominate investment for most people
most people is are just uh ignorance
funds they they mean that all those
trillions of dollars are invested
without any intelligent application
without knowing anything and the whole
purpose of investment is to get inside
get an Inside Edge that's the only only
thing that's what value is some new
insight that other people don't have but
the conflict of interest I guess they're
saying is that well somebody could say
hey we're going to build this up uh the
story of this company cuz we're invested
and we can we can ride things like
things like fraud are against the law or
right there's already there's already
laws for that already laws for that what
they're what the SEC doing is trying to
manipulate all the little intricacies of
how you launch an initial public
offering and in the and in the course of
it they've ended initial public
offerings which uh even Jang Zan the
former premere of China called the crown
jewels of American capitalism as the
process of IPOs and the SEC has a
managed to stifle IPOs we now have three
times as many IPOs in communist China as
in the United States that's the
achievement of the SEC and what happens
if this doesn't change because they seem
blind to it right they're completely
blind and after 2008 you know regulation
that's like don't let a good disaster go
to waste you know they want to just you
put in a bunch of new rules which are
more stifling yeah they they just keep
on putting in more stupid rules we do
have a scandal of money that i' that
I've uh described in my book Scandal of
money and and again and life after
Google life after Google by the way got
with been a bestseller in China all year
and I I spend a lot of my time in China
they've now China communist China is now
just published of wealth and poverty my
great celebration of capitalism of 30 40
years ago wow is now in all bookstores
all over China well you're a futurist uh
so is this going to change are we going
to are we going to wake up uh here or
what do you think's going to happen well
I think the financial system is reaching
a position where it where there's going
to be some sort of crash and I believe
that uh cryptocurrencies will win and
the question is whether the central
banks that are now issuing
cryptocurrencies I mean China
Estonia all these central banks have
projects for developing essentially
digital cryptocurrencies on blockchains
and whether the world will break into a
a bunch of
fragmented fiet currency IES rooted in
blockchains which will not really be a
much of an advance it'll be slight
increase in digitization but it will not
resolve the fundamental problem of a
measuring stick and a measuring stick
can't be part of what it measures so if
you have All the Monies of the world uh
based on figments of the Central Bank
and inflation measures that are guesses
of
economists uh you're not going to have
uh it's a sideways move not not progress
yeah wow so that becomes interesting so
you see that there is definitely some
kind of a reckoning coming um I think
there's a well i' I'm always I think
that people are increasingly aware that
the existing system is not working right
and I think the solutions are
Technologic iCal and I think the key to
the solutions
are blockchains and and related
cryptographic
Innovations and I think uh these are in
a great period of ascendency now and I
think that people who want to be part of
the
future should um learn about blockchains
understand how they work and why they
work and what the flaws are of the
current systems so that a new Foundation
of trust can be created for the world
economy and so that's interesting
because that's another variable you have
time you have trust right that that has
profound impact on economics yeah and
that blockchain could provide that yeah
so if you're going to continue to write
on this I assume so if I wanted to like
kind of keep up with your thoughts and
and oh yeah I mean I write every day
it's it's absurd age sub 79 but I'm
writing uh I do I have 100 close to
150,000 subscribers now I think to
my the daily prophecy gilder's daily
prophecy wow so I guess maybe a final
final question I'm embarrassed to say
it's almost free you just have to give
information which which is contrary to
my uh principles and uh life after
Google but but the world is full of
contradictions
isn't it
though what would Rand have to say about
that so final question do you consider
yourself primarily a philosopher you
know what do I consider my long distance
Runner I really get I enjoy running long
distances that's my great
gratification I I run in races all the I
win I'm 79 I beat the 7 year olds in
almost all my races no kidding wow how
far are you
running the longest I I compete in these
days is a half marathon really yeah 79
years old you're running half marathons
yeah I'm running one the Seattle half
marathon a year or so a couple years go
for over 70s so wow how are the knees
knees are fine occasionally have
Achilles tend in trouble but my knee is
fine wow well uh you know as I started
out saying this whole interview I feel
like I could I could talk to you uh for
10 hours rather than the short time we
have here but uh extraordinary insights
uh really really stimulating I really
appreciate you taking the time to share
them with us okay well thank you so much
for having me I really appreciate
it I really hope you're enjoying the
free viewing of the wealth breakthroughs
series and for those of you who already
jumped in and purchased the series I
want to give you a sincere thank you
this supports our work supports the
mission we have and getting this
information throughout the world people
need to understand wealth they need to
have their own wealth breakthrough and
you buying the series helps us get
everybody this information so thank you
so much for jumping in and doing exactly
[Music]
that
as you just saw George gilder's an
expert at picking a huge new tech Trend
years before it becomes reality but what
if you don't have years and years to
wait for a huge investing Trend to
develop Building Wealth on shorter
timelines than years and years is Greg
Gunner's life's work a Master Trader he
looks to get into big stock explosions
right before they happen then exit with
fast profits and he'll share the one
force in the market that consistently
outperforms all others here's Greg's
insightful interview it pulls back the
curtain on how stocks really work Greg
thanks for taking the time to sit and
have this conversation yeah glad to be
here so how did you get into doing what
you're doing today what was your path h
i me it's a long story I I grew up uh in
the 90s watching the tech bubble begin
to form and watching online trading
become this big huge thing where anybody
could get a brokerage account and with a
couple thousand bucks start trading
stocks and stocks just went up that's
all they did and so it felt like
everybody was getting rich and all this
is sort of happening around me as I'm
this kid in high school and so my
freshman year of college um was right at
the peak of the tech bubble and uh I was
talking to my dad on the phone from
school uh one day and he'd been talking
to me about the markets for a long time
and he's not a market professional or
anything like that but he was always
kind of interested in kind of prodding
me a long wanted to talk to me about
stocks and what I thought of them and
that sort of thing were you studying
Finance or I wasn't that's just it like
I really wasn't sure what I wanted to do
I was a typical College freshman you
know away from home kind of you know
feeling things out at school and um and
all this stuff is happening in the
markets and it's Peak hysteria you know
all these little tiny stocks are going
up you know they're doubling every
single day almost and my friends were
talking about stocks and so um I'm
speaking to my dad and he says you know
you're really smart Maybe you should you
know take some of that money you made in
high school working and uh put it in the
markets and try trading stocks trade
tech stocks I bet you do a good job and
so uh I was like yeah I'm going to do
that that's a great idea uh and I logged
on to erade uh I don't remember if it
was ER trade it might have been one of
the other ones but I logged on to one of
those you know first online brokerages
and I filled out all the info to open an
account and it said I needed a minimum
of like 1,500 bucks M to fund it and get
ready and I was like well it's almost
almost all the money I have right now
and I need money for pizza and textbooks
and all that stuff you need money for in
college and I said okay I was working a
job at the time on the side and going to
school once I saved another 1,500 bucks
I was going to get ready and figure out
this whole trading thing and make all
this money like everybody else was
making and I decided that right around
January of 2000 I think and the market
Peak three months later before I had the
money to actually dive in and at that
point the market had peaked it was
already going down and I figured oh that
was dumb who needs it you know and I
didn't think about it again for you know
several years so so it's interesting so
that basically if you'd gone in when you
went in you would I would have lost
everything there's no question about
it but I I think a part of the lesson
there though is that you didn't want to
go in with money that you really like if
you lost it would have been a big
problem for you right I mean I guess I
was smart enough to figure that one out
even at 18 years old I was like well
maybe I shouldn't you know Dive Right In
with my entire take your last money my
meager life savings you know that I
needed to survive off of and and buy
some no-name tech stock that would have
definitely gone to zero uh so I avoided
you know just by luck of you know the
draw yeah I avoided the big uh Tech
breakdown um so I ended up uh forgetting
about Finance for a few years and I got
into journalism and when I graduated
from college I started writing for
newspapers and that was my primary job
um while my timing uh avoiding the tech
bubble was good my timing getting into
the newspaper business was very bad
because this was right during the time
when newspapers were getting crushed by
the internet and laying off people left
and right right and uh I sat down one
day and I I was under so much pressure
and I was so stressed out about the
state of my industry and what I was
doing and how I would never be able to
get ahead and I decided I got to get out
of this I got to find something else to
do that I'm going to love and that's G
to make me some money so that I can
survive and um I came back to the
markets and uh I'd been trying to catch
up on the markets I'd been reading some
books and trying to figure things out
and um I applied for a bunch of jobs uh
to try to get into the world of finance
and I had no experience uh no degree in
economics or Finance any of that stuff
that you think you might need right you
know and uh no one took me up on it
until uh I got a call back uh from
someone at Agora Financial they were a
small growing Financial publisher and
they were looking for a junior analyst
to start talking about stocks writing
about investment ideas and that sort of
thing and uh they took a chance on me
and uh that's how I I got my start in
the world of Finance wow well I guess at
least your journalism paid off at that
point right because you're going to be
writing yeah exactly that was my foot in
the door like look I can string a couple
sentences together you know I I'm I'm
not a financial expert um i' I've read
some stuff I have some ideas but but
give me a shot and they did and lo and
behold some years later here you are a
financial expert so what is the what
what is it that you write about most uh
what I read about most is trading stock
trading and uh finding opportunities to
uh play momentum stocks and just for
distinction in case somebody doesn't
know the distinction uh trading versus
investing can you describe that yeah so
I'm looking at shorter term uh
opportunities in the stock market so
instead of buying a company because you
think 10 years down the road it's going
to be you know the the biggest and best
you know in its sector or industry uh
what I'm doing is I am
pinpointing uh spots in the market where
I think uh stocks are going to have a
big explosion higher and I'm grabbing
onto them as they're beginning to break
out and holding on for as long as I can
riding that bulll until it's time to get
off and it's usually a couple weeks uh
to a couple months tops okay so a couple
weeks to a couple of months and when you
say I think you might have just
described it but when you say momentum
stocks uh what would fit in that
category well I mean it depends on the
type of Market you're in but usually
these are the higher growth uh names the
ones that can move quickly in a very
short amount of time I'm not talking
about like boring dividend paying stocks
that sort of thing like the slow
grinders don't really interest me but as
far as trading is concerned you want the
stocks that can really pop and move so
you can get in Ride The Wave get out
move on to the next opportunity give me
an example of of one or two of those
that happened recently oh right now like
uh the time we're filming this I would
say like you know tech stocks you know
after getting hit with a little bit of a
correction are hot again now software
stocks that sort of thing usually it's
uh names on the NASDAQ you know a couple
years ago there was the Big Fang meme
that got started with you know the the
big internet stocks Facebook Google MH
those sort of things you know whatever
happens to be the invogue stock of the
time so at this point like let's say
something from the past like a Google or
a Facebook are they no would they no
longer be in a momentum category or are
there times when there might be a big
correction or pullback on them that you
might see them as a momentum stock again
they can be momentum stocks I mean they
are very big you know and they're very
established now but they're still in a
very hot industry and it seems like all
the growth now has moved into the tech
sector everything is Tech Domino's Pizza
is Tech now it's not just pizza really
you know so that so you would put
Domino's in Tech why because they you
know because of their app uh well no I
wouldn't put them in as Tech I'm saying
that everybody wants to be framed as a
tech I serly yeah they want to kind of
be in that lumped into the category
right it's like saying like uber Uber is
not a taxi company you know it's a tech
stock right you know it's uh there's
nothing new about hailing a cab but the
way they do it is technologically based
so that's a tech company ah very
interesting so what kind of analysis do
you do and and report on like what are
you looking for so I'm looking at charts
and I'm looking at buying and selling
pressure so technical analysis is what
you would call it as opposed to like
fundamental analysis where you're
pouring over you know like sales profit
margins that sort of thing I'm looking
strictly at Price movements uh to
determine when stocks are reaching
inflection points where they're most
likely to have big breakout moves higher
so do you recommend for people who want
to do momentum stock trading uh that
they basically stay liquid until you see
a certain thing form and then that's a
time to go in well yeah I mean you can
do it different ways you can have you
can have portfolios uh of longer term
like more Trend following picks like the
slow steady Grinders things like that
and then trade off of that so you don't
always have to be just sitting in cash
waiting for the next opportunity when
you say trade off of that what do you
mean by that well I'm saying if you have
like a long like some stocks that you're
holding for a longer term Trend you
don't have to necessarily have be
compressing your time frames you know um
the shorter the time frame the more uh
erratic a move can be right it's more
difficult to predict a move that happens
in two hours than it would be you know a
move that takes months to play out
that's just how the market works so you
can have some Trend following plays in
your portfolio where let's say like it's
like I want to be long tech stocks so I
have a core portfolio of a couple tech
stocks I really like and then to
supplement those gains that you're
making those profits you're making off
of these longer term Trend fing plays
you can have shorter term breakouts that
you're playing with your cash along the
way so that way you're always part of
your portfolio is always invested and
going with the E and flow of the market
and then you're strategically putting
money to work when the market gives you
those opportunities to play those
shorter term swing trades so let's say
that um I have
$200,000 in uh an account that I can
trade maybe it's a you know some kind of
retirement account or maybe it's just a
brokerage account and I'd say okay you
know what I'm going to do um I'm
listening to this interview and uh I
like this idea of momentum trading uh
I'm going to I'm going to liquidate 20%
you know the portfolio so I'll take
$40,000 and now I want to go find a
momentum stock to bet on more short term
and you know get in get out what would
my process be walk me through like say
okay here's kind of the things you
should be looking at or doing right well
everybody's process is different so you
have to find something that really works
for you because if you can't do stick
with it and and do it you know then
you're going to fail you have to believe
in what you're doing and really research
and figure it out but you have to you
have to be paying attention to price if
you're going to be trading stocks for
the short term you can't be fixated on
things like news coverage or what's
happening in politics or you know when
this company or what this company's
expecting for earnings or any of that
stuff none of that really matters in the
short term what matters is buyers and
sellers and where those inflection
points set up so you need to find spots
on charts that matter price points that
matter on charts and learn how to read
stock charts s and find those inflection
points and find those potential
breakouts and then you also have to be
disciplined enough to set stop losses
and know when to walk away from a trade
when it's not working out in your favor
that's probably the most important part
it's not a Buy and Hold proposition and
you're going to be wrong sometimes and
if you're not willing to walk away then
you're going to lose money consistently
instead of making money consistently do
you do it the other way do you do you
short stocks sometimes and find momentum
there or do you think that's too risky
uh some times uh it's very difficult to
short stocks because you know the old
saying the market takes the uh escalator
up and the elevator down so the moves on
the short side uh happen very quickly MH
and um you have to be in and out and you
have to very aggressively take profits
um a lot of uh beginning investors a lot
of advanced investors uh have trouble
making money shorting stocks so um I
feel like a better strategy than
shorting would be to know when to go
into cash and know when to sit on your
hands and wait for the next next long
opportunity to show up that's tricky to
do because when you're trading stocks
you know it it's exciting it's an
adrenaline rush and you always want to
be doing something but in reality the
market gives you these windows of
opportunity where like this is a really
good time to be trading and then it's
almost like the button on the on the
crafts table you know the button will
flip to off and it's probably not a good
time you know to be jumping in on the
long side of stuff you can find
different ways to hedge uh with like
inverse ETFs or something like that uh
but for the most part like shorting
stocks it's it's very very difficult I
would stick to Long trades personally
walk me through if you kind of use case
either uh an actual process where you
traded you did a momentum trade that
worked out or maybe somebody who follows
you you know did it where you're saying
okay you're analyzing different things
you saw these sort of numbers show up uh
you know on on the pricing you you know
you know you went in and here's you know
the here's how you went in did you go in
all the once or did you buy you know
through a period of time you know
multiple chunks and then here's how you
exited I would just like to you know if
you can feel the whole process what I do
is I do a top- down approach so relative
strength is very important to me and
what I mean by that is I want to trade
the strongest stocks in the strongest
sectors and the strongest part of the
market so I'm drilling down from what
sector is moving right now what is the
strongest sector on the market and when
I find that one then I drill down
another level and I say okay out of this
sector what are the stocks that are
really moving you know what's really
what's what's the rising tide here and
then I pinpoint those stocks and then
I'll look at those individual charts and
I'll say which of these charts poses the
best entry point the best inflection
point to get into a stock you know so
I'm I'm nailing my timing at that point
so can you give me an example of a
sector and a stock uh you just as an
example yeah sure so uh let's let's say
right now so we were just talking about
tech stocks so let's say right now now
I'm looking at like I'm looking at the
tech sector let's say the tech sector
looks really good okay the tech sector
is leading the market right now it's
bouncing back um what stocks are
outperforming in that sector right now
well let's look at the really big tech
stocks well Amazon's kind of lagging
Okay Google they look okay but it's not
a really great entry point even though
it's a strong stock but Facebook just
bounced off its 200 day moving average
it held that line perfectly MH and now
today it had a great looking big candle
so a nice big day higher was Up 3 %
while a lot of its peers are only up
like one and a half to so it's leading
its peers um and it's breaking out to
like let's say a new one month High mhm
so there you go you have your setup from
top down you looked at the tech sector
strongest sector on the market one of
the strongest sectors you found the
strongest stock that's helping lead them
higher and you've located a nice bounce
point a nice inflection point where it's
bounced off of reasonable support mhm
off of uptrending support and then you
have a little breakout to new highs over
whatever your short time frame is and
you don't feel like at that point you
missed it oh it already went up you you
feel like okay it's got momentum and I
it's going to continue well right that's
just it I that I think that's a mistake
that a lot of new Traders make is
they're they're constantly trying to
pick bottoms or pick the perfect entry
point well there's really not a picture
perfect entry point usually you'll get
them occasionally um but that's
something I see a lot people want to
bottom pick stuff they say oh I think
this is going to bounce here well wait
for some confirmation first you know
because everybody's looking at the
bottom of that chart saying oh it has to
stop it has to bounce right here it
doesn't have to do anything mhm you know
so you want that confirmation first and
if you want in you go ahead and buy it
like if you're if you're going to be
worrying about nickel and diming
yourself and missing that entry by a
couple pennies you're never going to get
into anything right you know you got to
be you got to be ready to make that
quick decision you see the setup you see
it breaking out you buy it mhm and now
uh do you set parameters up front too as
far as saying as soon as I get this much
uh profitability like I know you got the
stop going down absolutely do you have
the sell going up as far as saying
saying hey if it ever hits this I'm out
well sure so I like to set some targets
uh upside targets uh they're not perfect
they're never going to be you can't
predict the future you don't know what's
going to happen so uh what I like to do
um is know my time frame when I'm
getting into a trade if it's a quick
swing then I'm going to set a pretty
aggressive uh price Target and I'm going
to know when I want to get out I'm going
to measure the move and say like okay if
this gets up to the next resistance if
if I'm at 180 and the next resistance
looks like 200 then I'm going to want to
sell half at 200
or sell the whole thing at 200 depending
upon the circumstances so sometimes I'll
sell half and I'll let the rest ride if
I feel like I want to ride a bigger move
right and if it's a quick swing or if
earnings are coming up or something like
that could break the trend then I'm
going to want to sell the whole thing
take my double digit gains or whatever
they happen to be and then boom get
ready for my next big play and when you
use the term swing you know what do you
mean is I mean literally like you're
stepping up to the plate and taking a
swing or what do you mean by Swing Swing
just means a shorter term trade a swing
trade can uh play out over a matter of
days or weeks as opposed to like a
position trade which might take a little
bit longer that's just terminology yeah
so it's it's longer than a day trade but
much longer than a day trade yeah I
don't do any day
trading why not well I like I said like
uh the shorter the time frame the harder
it is to predict the movement and again
like I feel like you're picking up
pennies in front of a steamroller
sometimes with the day trading stuff you
know I mean if you're just gonna turn
yourself through 20-day trades just
trying to make a like what $500 a day
you've wasted a lot of time when you
could be looking for that one good move
that one good trade you know that's
going to get you much bigger gains over
the course of a week or two than just a
small day trade some people day trade
very successfully if that's what they
want to do it's not my style right so so
when you're publishing and you you're
writing constantly I imagine daily on
this stuff you're writing all the time
what kind of things are you writing
about uh where you think the momentum uh
is in the market or you know are you you
giving stock picks yeah so do you spend
most of your time just in analysis
looking at all this stuff I do I spend
all my time doing that so um I write
every day uh and I write about the
market and I put the market in context I
think that's an important thing because
uh Traders uh especially newer Traders
get so fixated on news and politics and
all this other this other noise that
they think really affects the markets um
and a lot of the times that doesn't
matter you know everybody thinks that
they can oh well if I only knew this
ahead of time I could have I could have
bought this or sold this but in reality
it's not true if you gave me a list of
what uh all these different banks
earnings are going to be that are
reporting tonight that comes out
tomorrow I wouldn't be able to tell you
what the Stock's going to do because
it's all about the reaction to the
earnings that matters not the earnings
themselves it's not the number that's
not the headline number that you see
it's the Market's reaction to those
earnings that that matters yeah you
could have a company that that beats all
the analyst estimates and for whatever
reason somebody coughed on the
conference call and somebody didn't like
it sold and everybody else sold and so
it's down the next day and everybody
pulls their hair out you know trying to
figure out what the heck just happened
there with that I thought they did well
I thought they beat earnings but the
market didn't like it so they didn't so
yeah so this is the really interesting
thing because there's this thing called
the market right it's like this this
Force you know that's out there and
you've got a bunch of really really
smart people all of whom you know have
perspective and you know they've been
you know detailed you know analysis of
the market Etc yeah but in the end
nobody can really predict it's it's a
very unpredictable phenomenon from that
perspective right so with the way that
you approach it um saying okay I'm not
going to worry about the psychology
day-to-day so much uh but I'm going to
just look for because as you said you do
a technical analysis you know you're
just saying I'm I'm looking for price
points how they're holding seeing you
know what sector it's in if it feels
strong and the bottom seems safe then I
see something break out I'm going to
take a ride with it for a while it's
like catching a wave I guess like a
surfer it's absolutely catching a wave
analogy okay so that's yeah that's what
what it feels like so if you're someone
who let's say is like you real expert on
this you write on it you know people
follow you Etc what would my what would
I expect on an annual basis if I was
doing this in a reasonably competent way
what kind of return on my money would I
expect to get year-over-year well I mean
it it really depends it depends on the
market conditions um I think what you're
really striving to do is you're striving
to beat a Buy and Hold portfolio right
so if the S&P is up 5% in a year you're
trying to beat that Mark and I think
that's really easy to do with the swing
trading strategy as long as you have a
disciplined approach to it right now um
I think your returns can vary year to
year you can have a market that's very
difficult to trade um you know people
always are worried about markets that
are going down oh we're going to have a
bare Market or a big correction I'm not
so much worried about those I I don't
like choppy markets choppy sideways
markets can be very difficult a range
bound Market because you have to be in
and out um and you have to do a lot of
mean reversion type trades instead of
breakouts um and it can be much more
frustrating it's a lot more fun to trade
markets that are breaking out to the
upside yeah you know or waiting out some
sort of a corrective move where you can
sort of like get your eggs in a basket
and figure out what your next move is
going to be and if there is some kind of
a massive correction if you have your
your your stop wers in then you know you
know that you're you limit the amount of
risk that you have while you're doing
this type of trading right I mean again
you know when you're trading it's not a
Buy and Hold
strategy as long as it and I'm not
saying this is easy but as long as
you're sticking to your stop losses
you're going to take some losses when
the market starts going down but you're
not going to take near the hit that a
Buy and Hold investor is going to take
during a draw down if you're playing
your cards correctly and I imagine if
you're averaging it over time you know
hey you know just factor that in uh at
some point there's going to be maybe a
correction uh for some period of time
where you we go to a u you some kind of
a bare Market uh but you've limited your
losses you get you had all these gains
while you had a bull run you that's just
a part of the game if you want your
Equity curve to look a lot better don't
worry so much about growing it during a
correction or a bare Market worry about
just keeping it flat right because the
Buy and Hold people or losing money if
you just keep yours flat when the
Market's going down you're already eight
steps ahead of them when the market
starts recovering and then you're ready
to hit the ground running when stock
start setting back up on the long side
again how much time do you have to spend
doing uh you this type of momentum
trading uh you to be able to be
effective do you know is it hours a day
or you know an hour a day or I mean if
you have help then not a lot of time at
all because what kind of help do you
mean well if you're reading you know
like like if you got information coming
from people like you yeah absolutely
then then I you know I can I can do all
the work for you or something like that
but for me I spend a majority of the day
when the markets are open watching the
markets and analyzing the moves and
trying to figure out uh what I should be
trading uh so yeah I mean it does take a
lot of time and as far as like
experience goes you know I mean the
market is not a stagnant thing it
changes all the time um every time you
think you have something figured out
it's going to change and you have to be
ready to adapt so um from that
perspective I mean my work's never going
to be done right you know I'm never
going to like be able to be like okay I
got it I can just sit back now and trade
this way and it's always going to work
and I'll be just fine can somebody uh
like myself you know I have a full-time
career uh but uh you what you're talking
about makes sense of me day trading way
too risky takes too much time well too
much time too I mean people people look
at day trading they say oh look at that
I could get all this Freedom you know
day trading like no you'd be glued to a
computer yeah you're going to be really
paying attention day at least at least
it's your job you're allowed to take
lunch and go to the bathroom right you
so I mean I don't I don't see that as
really an answer I think I think more of
an answer would be like a position
trading strategy or swing trading
strategy where you know you're
concentrating your trades on you know a
few really nice setups where you can
wake up in the morning look at what the
Market's doing make your decisions put
in your orders and then call it a day
you know yeah so it doesn't take a whole
lot of time but like you said the the
research is what takes time but you know
that's where you know that's why you you
do what you do you can provide uh you
you can spend your days doing that so
other people don't have to right yeah
that's and and obviously if it's what
you're doing all the time then you have
better context uh than than most people
would have and on the other side of it
like you said like you know the kind of
the the long-term invest you know the
Buy and Hold for forever uh that can be
a little stagnant or depressing even so
this is kind of like that in between
stage where you like to play I have
nothing against Buy and Hold I mean
everybody should be buying and holding
in a retirement account or something
like that as long as you're really truly
holding don't touch it yeah you know
don't look at it um but yeah I mean with
with with trading if you have research
that you trust and you you kind of get
yourself into a groove it could be
something you can do before work in the
morning or after work take take a look
at you know the markets and see where
things are and it can be it can be a fun
hobby yeah it really can be but yeah day
trading that's a little bit too much uh
it's a little bit too much work for me
so technical analysis you know you said
at one point you you know the banks
might report XY or Z but you don't know
how somebody how the Market's going to
respond or somebody sneezes on a
conference call you know the market does
whatever crazy things it might do you
you mention these things uh is there is
there psychology around uh technical
analysis when you're you know when
you're analyzing the types of things
that you do well it is it is behavioral
psychology that's what technical
analysis is at its core it's the study
of buyers and sellers and their
relationship with the markets and that's
what that's what I'm doing every day
people hear technical analysis and they
think about squiggles on charts and um
some people think it's the
self-fulfilling prophecy or it's Voodoo
or whatever else or they just don't
believe in it or they say it's it's a
shortcut cut um to try to squeeze some
you know a few pennies out of the market
um but what they fail to see is it is
the study of buyers and sellers and of
price and I could sit here all day with
a whiteboard and draw you charts and
show you patterns and that sort of thing
and you might remember some of the silly
names that people have used as shortcuts
for them um but in reality price has
memory if you look at a chart and you're
drawing a line on a chart MH through $50
and you see there's a lot of touches $50
back in March stock bumped up against
$50 and then went back down and then in
June it did the same thing a lot of hits
on $50 well $50 mean something because
that's where a lot of people have bought
this stock and sold this stock so price
has memory and so when I'm looking for a
breakout in a stock I'm looking for
touches on price and I'm going back and
I'm seeing what prices mattered to
buyers and sellers at that time you know
your opinions on since we talked about
Facebook stock today probably aren't
very strong if you don't own the stock
but as soon as you buy it you know you
have an emotional attachment to the
price you paid for that stock right
every single Trader or investor does
that's what matters I bought Facebook at
$50 or whatever it happens to be we can
use that to our advantage when we're
trading because we know where these
inflection points are by graphing them
out on a chart and seeing where we're
going to run out of buyers or run out of
sellers at a particular spot and where
people are going to say okay you know
what I'm sitting on these gains I'm not
selling for 50 I'll sell for 55 maybe
and people are less likely to sell their
shares at that time and so then you have
a situation where the stock could
possibly break out now that you're
saying it it makes perfect sense to me I
never would thought about it like that
before but you're exactly right it's
like yeah there's seems to be like you
some sort of an artificial ceiling here
that is psychological and once it breaks
through it it creates a new psychology
now oh okay so it's gone through 50 and
it holds and it continues oh now
everybody's reframed themselves about
the stock so that's really interesting
well it's like how people uh will say oh
I don't want to buy that stock cuz it's
gone up too far mhm that Stock's at
all-time highs I don't want to buy it
now I'll wait for it to pull back why
wouldn't you want to buy a stock at
alltime highs yeah everybody who's
bought is in the green they don't want
to sell that move is probably going to
continue higher that's a great time to
buy a stock don't buy a stock when it at
it's lows that's a time when we can's
probably want to sell or they're
thinking about oh maybe this time I give
up on this thing it's garbage but when
it stocks at highs go for it you know
very interesting wow well I'll tell you
this is you know the market is endlessly
fascinating and uh you know how people
view it and approach it you know also
very fascinating but the whole idea is
like you know okay um you know I'm not
going to I've got I make a certain
amount of money but I've got to take
this money and do something with it to
actually develop some wealth uh and some
security in my future so uh it sounds
like that you certainly have one way to
approach that and maybe make that happen
so I appreciate you spending the time to
uh to share all this with us oh my
pleasure
[Music]
our next interview is one of my
favorites like you saw with George
Gilder earlier the tech coming online
now that'll change all of our Lives
reads like a laundry list of profit
chances AI robotics blockchain new
computer advances the commercialization
of space and one man's been profiting
from all these things over and over
again for years his name is Ray Blanco
if Ray's name is familiar to you it's
because he's been part of the
phenomenally successful technology
profits confidential service from St
Paul's research for the last decade the
gains Ray racked up for readers rival
some of the best hedge fund returns on
the planet over that time and raise
letter cost an absurdly low $49 a year
raise one of the smartest Tech
researchers out there and a tech nerd
just just like me this is one of my
favorite interviews and you should pay
close attention to reay's discussion of
what his research says is the biggest
wealth creation event in history and
it's just getting
started R I'm really uh excited and
interested to have this conversation
because we've had a few interviews over
time uh talking about the markets and
how you've been picking stocks and you
know you've you're one of the Premier
experts out there in the areas that you
work in right tell us a little bit about
uh your background and how you got to be
doing uh the work you do today sure so
I've always had a very deep interest in
technology um science the future you
know was a real sci-fi buff as a kid
it's kind of spilled over into my adult
life uh you know I studied Tech uh you
know worked uh you know computer science
and worked in both private and public uh
uh
organizations uh you know technology
saved my life too I mean as a cancer
survivor you know the stuff that they
used to help me you know didn't exist a
decade or two previously so it's always
been something of great interest to me
um and you know I've worked for
investment firms on the technology side
I've seen some of the classic blunders
that investors can make when there's new
disruptive technology but they're
investing in and and and the and the
stuff that's going out you know and
things like that so uh that's something
that you know many years of of life
experience I've been able to bring to
what I do today so suddenly we we're
faced with this huge disruption like
that the known universe has just shifted
and uh and I'm wondering now how that
has uh impacted your thinking and
observation so can we start with a a
macro view uh of just kind of like okay
here's the general things that I'm
seeing and then maybe we'll get more
specific into some of the companies
you're studying right now sure sure so
um I think any kind of 2020 prediction
you might have read at the end of 2019
December pretty much got thrown out the
window really quickly uh with what's
been going on this year of course uh the
big the big disruption has been the uh
the covid-19 uh epidemic started uh in
China apparently late Summer and the
fall and uh it spread you know we
haven't really dealt with something like
this as a society in a long time it's at
its foundation it's a health problem but
the economic repercussions of dealing
with it have been pretty incredible you
know tens of millions of people lost
work lots of small businesses shuttered
and uh you know the federal government
taking Extraordinary Measures to prop up
the economy over this period of time um
there will be some stuff will be
shortlived and bounce back fast M but
there will be long-term effect effects
that we're never going back to the old
normal there's going to be a new normal
uh and that does present challenges but
it also presents a lot of opportunities
were you shocked uh at like how quick
the market seemed to come back uh you
given that we still we're dealing with
at least at the time of this recording
we're still dealing with a good amount
of uncertainty a little bit um I I
expected the market to bottom in March
man I was right it it pretty much did
bounce back really quick not to where
its old level was before uh the covid-19
virus was started to be taken seriously
by the
market uh but you know I mean you know
the NASDAQ 100's up for the year uh you
know major ETFs are doing really well
biotech Tech is doing really really well
you know the Federal Reserve stepped in
pumped a lot of money into the economy
they're talking about backstopping you
know the stock market lately um it's
just the government respon is you know
there's a disconnect between Wall Street
and Main Street here obviously but it
you know the market has performed
extraordinarily well under the
circumstances so do you think that we
can trust it in other words there's
there's there's two people saying hey
you know the fed's backing the
government's saying they're going to
prop the market up that's all the
confidence we need this is going to hold
up and there's other people saying it's
a paper tiger I mean you know it's it's
just not real and at some point you know
there's people know how to play the game
they're going to take huge profits and
the whole thing is going to really you
know squat again so what what do you
think well there's never anything wrong
with taking a huge profit right you know
there is of course risk if you want no
risk you can put your money in in a
certificate of deposit MH um but you
know there's only a limited amount of
places where people can put their money
expect a reasonable return and the stock
market is liquid it is easy to access
and it's an easy place for people to do
that um so there's only so many places
you can park your money you know earn a
return and and that's going to prop up
the market for I think a long long time
to come now your areas uh include you
know Tech and biotech you you really
investigate those areas um and uh you
know the NASDAQ uh you know I think is
actually at one point fully recovered uh
you from its from you know the lows to
the you know the highs and you know you
know it's going to be back and forth I
imagine for some time uh so just
starting uh with maybe one more General
Outlook uh do you think there's still
going to be a good amount of of
volatility in this market for the
foreseeable future yes and there will be
a lot of headline risk depending on the
es and flows of the epidemic and how we
deal with it I like that term the
headline risk talk about that well I
mean you get some some big news you know
bad news uh regarding the virus that we
didn't know before you could see the
markets drop on that or you could get
some really good news you know some
medical breakthrough or new discovery
just just a few days ago you know this
week uh we learned about an
off-the-shelf drug that we have that
seems to be pretty decent in helping
people uh recover so things like that
will rally the market and if there's bad
news there you know the Market's going
to react in a negative way yeah you know
I I just never heard that that that term
before but I like it you know because I
S of have that feeling as somebody who's
you know kind of watching this fairly
closely is that man it's just like
there's so much psychology here you know
one headline and boom you suddenly
everything really drastically changes
so that that volatility is is an
interesting thing do you um you know I
know from our prior conversations you
you normally are somebody goes out
really looks at fundamentals studies a
company you'll actually show up at
places Etc and and figure out where to
place you know your your bets and do it
in areas that you have particular
expertise uh do you do anything right
now trying to uh you know take some
profit off the table from the volatility
or are you still oh okay so talk about
yeah well we've done very well on um a
small uh drug development companies I
mean we've just a couple weeks ago we
took a 500% profit on one W you know the
week after that something like a 200%
profit on another one uh just companies
with stuff that they're working on that
could be dual use with covid-19 they've
gone to the Moon um as you know possible
problem solvers and when you get those
those big uh run-ups that don't look
sustainable MH uh you do take a profit
at least a partial profit and uh you
know it's been very good for the
portfolio so that's interesting um you
know as you're as you're studying this
because uh a lot of people are placing
you know their investment or their bets
and saying okay this is a company maybe
they read your newsletter and and say I
like what Ray's saying about this I'm
going to put some money into that
company uh and I heard you use the
phrase and we you know we took some
profits you know 500% or what have you
on on some of these trades you some how
do you determine well now's a good time
to come out or some take some of that
profit as compared to saying uh we
should let this ride I think this
company's going to continue to do better
uh H how do you make that decision well
I mean uh if a if a company's double
that's an easy decision take half your
money out that way no matter what
happens you know you're not going to
lose your original investment and you're
basically playing with house money which
is a great place to be right other cases
I think you know good companies with
prospects can get ahead of themselves
and you know you you take a profit on
that and if they decline liter on you
get a good position to reenter then you
do that right so it's it's a timing
situation and I guess you just kind of
study it and you get a feel and then
decide CU like if you're sitting there
saying ah this is up 400% right now and
we're one head headline away from it
dropping maybe I should at least take
some or or all of it out at that point
yeah I mean we've got a catalyst in a
couple of weeks it could be good m it
could be bad uh but we're up this much
why are we going to risk it um holding
through the Catalyst even if it's a good
Catalyst people sometimes oftentimes
sell on you so let's take a profit now
which is something I often advise yeah
that's really really interesting so I
guess now as we get into it um you know
what sectors are you uh mostly focused
on now and and and maybe what companies
do you want to talk about and I will say
you know that when somebody watches this
and people be watching this at different
times things can change so we're talking
you know you know at this moment but
that that seems to be the thing you like
to talk about hey you I I like this
company here's why here's what's going
on so uh maybe tell us a couple of your
top thoughts right now and maybe the why
behind it because that will help inform
us not just here's a company I like but
here's why I like the company and that
might teach us how to look at companies
ourselves sure so you know as I
mentioned earlier um this is
fundamentally at its root a health
problem and the
only companies with the the set of tools
to actually fix that problem or you know
companies in the health space
biotechnology companies so uh companies
that I like and I've talked about uh to
my subscribers I do like Gilead a great
deal this is a one of the great biotechs
of all time uh was originally founded to
deal with infectious disease viruses and
so on um you know helped turn HIV from a
uh death threat to a chronic health
condition you know in the 201
they a drug that basically eradicates
hepatitis C M uh you know just done a
lot of really excellent work uh so this
company had a a drug colorum dese which
I'm sure everybody's heard of it's been
in the news a lot uh originally
developed for Ebola um seems to provide
some benefit for covid-19 uh one study
that the NIH undertook um showed that
reduces hospital stays by three or 4
days MH so um you know this is a company
that's uh got a drug that actually has
clinically shown benefit they've given
away you know 1.5 million
doses uh to the public but there's still
I think a lot of profit potential I
don't think um this virus is going to be
over in a few months we're going to be
living with this for a while so there's
a lot of Revenue potential for Gilead
there uh another big biotech name I like
regeneron um antibody portfolio Tech
techology that they have there so they
just started clinical trials for an
antibody cocktail so basically they
studied people that have recovered they
take blood samples they look at what
antibodies these people's you know
bodies are producing and then they
engineer copies of them so they've got
um a cocktail of two that they believe
will neutralize the virus is not a
long-term solution but if you're in a
high-risk situation um you could conce
you know if this does does get approved
you could conceivably you know get an
injection of this and it'll give you a
protective benefit for for a period of
time uh older people same thing you know
people that are at Great risk maybe your
first responder for example so those are
a couple of companies I like on the
therapeutic side uh there's other
companies that are trying to repurpose
existing drugs there's a lot of uh drugs
therapies you know that um work in some
way by tamping down
the uh in you know immune system
reaction the inflammatory reaction to
infection which is really what kills
people you know their immune system amps
up to such a degree that it starts
destroying lung tissue and so on um it's
called a cyto kind storm so if if you
can give some like uh you know the
steroid that was recently published um
it it works by tamping down the
inflammatory response to infection so
there's a lot of companies out there
working on it from that angle uh there a
lot of vaccine companies there's a
number that I do like as well working on
uh not just vaccines in general but
breakthrough new vaccine platform
Technologies uh for example uh Inovio
Pharmaceuticals which is uses a DNA
technology the DNA once it's inside your
cells um expresses the code for uh an
antigen related to the spike protein on
the virus another one is Mna is that DNA
or RNA DNA okay cuz there are some RNA
vaccines MNA one working on
RNA um also in in human clinical trials
both of them are yeah just as a uh you
my own personal disclaimer you know I'm
not a big fan of of of the vaccine or
pharmaceutical uh practices very often
so yeah I I want you to talk about them
from the from the financial standpoint I
I just uh worry personally about a
FastTrack vaccine that might be forced
on people but that's yeah me too I mean
we need to do this on as voluntary a
basis as humanly possible yeah but these
these vaccine Technologies are not like
um the stuff that's been out there for
decades there's reason to believe that
they're going to be a lot safer they're
not going to have you know adant that
contain mercury and stuff like that uh
they work by different mechanisms you
know you're not using an inactivated
virus for example uh which could be
problematic it is for some people so um
you know hopefully we'll see something
emerge from here and there's still a lot
we don't know we don't know if a vaccine
will provoke a durable response to this
Corona virus over the long term tell me
if this is a premise you work with when
you're thinking when you're looking at
companies to invest is uh you seem to
say hey I'd like companies that already
are in the business and have a track
record as compared to newer companies
that are basically more um in the early
phases of their of their company I mean
take somebody who's got track record
because some of these companies like
you're going back to like hey they were
working during the AIDS epidemic right
you know and they're still in the game
but they they show a track record so is
it accurate to say that you you bias
towards those types of companies as
compared to newer companies that don't
have that kind of track record I like a
high low mix MH okay a lowrisk you know
companies like the Gilead and the
regenerant where even if whatever
they're doing for covid-19 doesn't pan
out you still have a solid business
there and a bunch of other avenues of
growth uh so that's the lower risk side
and then I do like the higher risk as
well where you got these emerging
biotechs that don't have anything on the
market yet but they have a lot of
promise and they could be the next
Gilead or regeneron right so you know
those are the ones where you're you're
going to potentially capture some decent
gains off the uh the low-risk companies
but the high-risk ones are the ones that
give you that really huge upside
potential but you know with the risk of
not that much upside do you have a a
ratio that you personally use relative
to low high saying I you I kind of go
this much into low risk and this much
into high risk it depends on the actual
portfolio we're talking about I've got
lower risk larger better better
capitalized companies than some mhm and
others are just moonshots so you know I
wouldn't recommend putting your money
you can't afford to lose in these kinds
of companies but if you don't own a
sufficient number of them you tend to do
quite well over time do you do you put
like 5% of your portfolio or your your
investment money or 10% % in like the
moonshots like you know where's your you
know something like 5 or 10% probably a
good idea in your in a personal yeah
portfolio it depends on your tolerance
for risk what your you know your
timeline is how long you intend to hold
and things like that so that varies a
lot individual individual are you
finding yourself trading uh a lot more
meaning holding stocks not as long as
you typically do during all this time
and uh so tell me you tell me how much
that has changed I mean are you like you
know are you very busy every day like
really yeah we're turning a little bit
more um just because of the volatility
you know you get these opportunities to
get in on you know like when the market
bottomed in March right there was just
huge opportunity in just some in just
great companies that had been unfairly
sold off that wouldn't be fundamentally
impacted by the economic Fallout of
covid-19 okay they're in you know
defensive Industries like you know
Healthcare or something like that so um
you know this on the you know there's
opportunity to get in short term and
wait for the bounce and then on the um
on on on the other side is some of these
companies have just spiked hundreds of
percent in a matter of weeks just
because they put out some press releases
that they're involved in some way with
co9 well you know you take a profit on
those quick yeah and that's because that
hype isn't going to last forever I was
going to say I see press releases and
you know and literally I can read them
and say oh this is written by a PR firm
it really isn't saying much of anything
I mean it's there's a little little
something here but it seems like a
disproportionate you know response as
far as the stock you know climbing so
quickly i' I've seen some of those yeah
why does that Happ I mean isn't isn't
the market in the investment Community
pretty smart and Savvy why why why are
why do those pops happen you know it's
traders in the short term the market is
uh is a voting machine isn't that what
Warren buff said I think the short term
it's a voting machine in the long term
it's a weighing machine so in the short
term you get you know these and then you
get people chasing that price action you
get that momentum Traders you know going
in there and you get that kind of
movement
so in the short term they're not that
smart you know people make their
short-term profit profits and other
people don't you mentioned uh Warren
Buffett um and uh you know he wanted to
sit for an interview but we didn't have
room for him I'm just
kidding so but uh what is he doing right
have you been observing him at all just
trying to get a sense of his thing I
don't I don't really follow him closely
I've got a couple of
dog paperbacks I read back in the day
yeah about his investment philosophy so
uh you know I think he's been getting he
got out of Airlines or something I heard
that he's he's he's been getting you to
cash which is uh which is weird because
one of his books that I read way back
said how he got into Airlines and it
didn't work out for him and he got out
of Airlines realizes you know this is a
lousy business to invest in cuz it's
very Capital intensive the you know the
margins are razor thin I guess he
changes mind got back in the airlines I
don't know for some reason yeah and I
I've read some you know about why he was
taking some of those positions but
that's you know and I know this isn't
necessarily your area but that's like
another kind of crazy place right the
Airlines and right you how are they
going to adapt to this and you know you
had to fly here for this this interview
and and you know you're supposed to come
a different day they change your flights
on you there and you know we we've had
similar experiences it's you we had to
let go of how convenient air travel was
and how you know you can really rely on
it it's it's a new game now for now
right yeah so in your areas that you do
study um are there any of those that
you're saying boy these people are you
this area is really compromised or these
particular companies are really
compromised because of what's going on
right now yeah I mean there's a lot of
areas that that are particularly weak um
you know retail brick and mortar but
people's habits are changing so um
there's trends that are emerging from
all this so people are stuck at home
they're scared to go out um you know
they've been doing a lot more online
buying M um you know a lot more digital
payments instead of dirty people don't
want to dirty handle filthy cash because
of the virus so they're switching to
more to plastic and even more so to
contactless payments where you don't
even have to touch a terminal people are
engaging in tele medicine for me it was
the first time uh here a couple months
ago engaging with my healthc care
provider and it was all remote so
there's a there's trends that are on the
upside that were already there
technology trends that are being
accelerated by all this you know tella
Health work from home study from home
yeah um you know there's been a number
of companies done very well their stocks
have done very well because of that I I
have to speculate that that that that's
going to be a boom because you know just
even looking at my my mother you know uh
who needed consult we a cardiologist and
you know not having to you know get in a
car drive to a place show up at a
facility sit and wait normally a long
time in a reception get in you know have
the an appointed time in front of the
computer and and literally I don't know
that uh much was lost for an existing
patient that's been managed for a period
of time right doesn't seem like much is
lost and maybe once a year you still
want to have like a let me let me look
at you type of a thing so do you think
uh you know and I'm purely speculating
you study this stuff but I'm speculating
the tellah health is probably going to
really be explosive after this so what
do you think yeah I mean we've we've
done really well on teleah health names
um you know one company we sold for
close to 200% was tedoc which is one of
the Premier pure plays on T medicine you
know they've done really well other
companies on in the you know living at a
distance and not uh doing things uh face
to face so much companies like slack and
so on have done really well uh and then
there's you know embedded Tech Trends
you all this stuff put strain on the
communications infrastructure uh that
means investment in networking equipment
and um and beefing up that Network
infrastructure cloud computing all that
stuff is being boyed up by just our
changes in lifestyle which I believe
will be very sticky I mean you're going
to see a lot of people I'm just as
productive working from home yeah you
know the employer says why am I paying
for all this leasing all this office
space if my employees are doing so well
from home right maybe have a smaller uh
location maybe meet up once a week or
something like that and uh you know they
can work from home the rest of the time
I think there's a lot of uh uncertainty
around commercial real estate right now
right so I'd be worried about that yeah
have you spoken to Providers uh you know
because I'm looking say from the patient
side but how providers feel about telea
health are they like hey you know I kind
of like you know this also or do they
want to get back to face Toof face
visits well it does make them more
productive they can see more patients MH
um in a given amount of time it's less
expensive to provide care mhm in that
sense on the patient side you know you
don't have to miss at least half a day
of work miss those wages drive across
town right you know it makes a lot of
sense it does make a lot of sense um it
you know for somebody's got some
something that needs constant
management um it's useful there because
you can you can be in touch with your
provider a lot more without with with
less
inconvenience and I think there's going
to be all kinds of other stuff that's
going to follow on the back of this it
won't just be tell Health in the sense
of uh interacting with your provider uh
I think we're going to see some
diagnostic
Technologies uh at home stuff coming out
here over the next few years I mean
imagine just a little drop of blood I'm
not talking about Theos here okay but
but you know the technology is moving in
that direction where a little finger
stick of blood at home you put it in the
analyzer it's very user friendly and it
monitors your you know your whatever
whatever the uh the molecular diagnostic
that you need monitored and it uploads
to the cloud your doctor gets the
results in 10 minutes you know stuff
like that I think that's that's the
future that's coming uh I have a small
brokerage account that I have my uh my
just recently college graduated son
manage and he was holding Zoom early and
did really well with it so Zoom
obviously is like you know everybody's
doing Zoom now are there uh there's got
to be competition growing for Zoom I
imagine and if so are there are there
any startups or any people that you like
zoom's nothing in my opinion so when I
look at technology companies I really
like to see some sort of emote MH okay
um what do you mean by emote just so we
can understand some sort of the best
business is a monopoly business where
there is no competition so like
biotechnology companies I mean there's a
natural built-in mode okay around I come
up with some gwiz cancer therapy okay
I've got Market exclusivity for 10 15
who knows how many years okay uh nobody
can sell my product I'm the only one
that can sell it and I can you know
demand very high pricing for that which
from a business perspective is great so
uh in technology I like to look at that
some sort of Secret Sauce patent
portfolio uh some technology that they
solely control and you know we've been
web aing and I mean how many
face-to-face video chat technologies
have we been using over the years I mean
what is it that makes Zoom so special I
think it's the ease of use it's ease of
use you don't even need to have an
account with them right to use it but
that's also that's something that's
easily copied by anybody that's number
one number two it's incure you know they
had some security problems and
fundamentally that system is not secure
you can't make it secure right I don't
see how they can do it so they either
get rid of that super easy interface
that allowed them to kill everybody in
that market you know or they stay
insecure yeah and what's interesting is
because what's its real value now I just
think is it's brand Equity right I mean
the adoption rate is everybody just know
hey you want to do a zoom call hey are
doing Zoom so everybody's doing it where
I think maybe more serious business is
going to move to a more secure platform
it needs to but the consumer grade where
people say what am I worried about I'm
just talking to my my aunt you know or
something you know they don't you maybe
they don't worry so much uh are there
people that maybe with more secure
platforms uh that maybe have some uh
they have a moe you have to use your
phrase that you're looking at that you
like in teleconferencing I I really
don't I mean I haven't looked at the
space enough to say that there is
somebody but I'm not aware of anybody
that's got that secret sauce um that
would put them in that kind of a
position yeah you know in the tella
Health space t do I think what's really
important there is their relationships
with major uh healthc care uh
organizations insurance companies you
know networks and things like that that
have put them in a in a pretty in a
pretty good spot I don't see a zoom on
on their own end having quite that kind
of a protective situation around them
yeah interesting so uh anything else
that that uh you know as we're looking
at now um postco you know Trends or
behaviors you know so we looked at sort
of the health side you know a little bit
of the tech side anything else you think
technologically that might start to uh
flower or Bloom that we should be
considering you know just yesterday you
know the president was talking about a
trillion dollar uh infrastructure
package so um there's a tremendous Tech
opportunity there it's it'll happen with
without the package but the package I
think will be very beneficial and
accelerating and that's next Generation
Wireless 5G um you know the buildout has
barely begun I know they're advertising
5G out there you can 5G handsets and
things like that but it's not real 5G
okay what is real 5G real 5G is going to
incorporate a lot more additional
technology you know different
frequencies of radio you know of radio
waves um you know a lot more small cells
cuz these frequencies don't travel a
great distance you're going to see your
device is going to be multiplexing
multiple different uh types of uh
technology at the same time into one
logical Channel and then there's stuff
that's people don't think of as 5G but
5G is a network of network so it's going
to incorporate not just 4G but this new
stuff and you know even satellites in
space and things like that there's a
there's a movement uh you know uh like
an anti anti 5G movement where they feel
like um you know there's health concerns
and you know testing and you know you
they talk about the v's you know that
you know uh you know colony collaps of
these types of things do you think that
um there's a threat to it or is it going
to be irrepressible this thing is
rolling out and no matter well I I think
it's pretty irrepressible and the
evidence on the uh on the anti side I
think is is really weak I mean they've
been talking to us about you know the
the the danger of Wireless fre years
period you know oh smartphones cause
cancer and all this stuff but if you go
and look at the government um sear
database where they track yearly cancer
cases and you know mortality rates and
it's you know subdivided by cancer type
um you know you look at something like
brain cancer you look at 20 years of
data I mean you got to admit you know
cell phone is exploded over the last 20
years right you know if if uh holding
that to your head and getting those
frequencies you know going through you
were to cause cancer I would expect
brain cancer to go up uh at least a
little bit but we've seen it flat to
maybe slightly down yeah F the the new
5G frequencies they they penetrate even
less than the old ones that's why they
don't travel that far M you know just
rain and and structures block them a lot
more um you know and they aren't
ionizing radiation to begin with not
like x-rays or gamma rays or other types
of rays um that they uh they can you
know break strands of DNA and cause
mutations and things like that so you
know there isn't really a
credible body out there not the World
Health Health Organization I don't know
about their credibility these days the
Centers for Disease Control uh FCC I
mean you name it none of them have come
out and said you know we found that this
is you know dangerous to human life so
yeah yeah it's interesting um you know
i' I've uh looked at and even like
attended some of these like you have
Summits where they're talking about all
this and all the papers they site and
then you know and I've seen the other
side you know what you're saying and
we're here to talk about investment so
for for people who are investing you
know they have you know Europe opinions
they don't need to have a concern that
that there might be something that takes
5G down or doesn't allow it to roll out
I don't I don't see it happening it's a
question of when not if and how quickly
we're going to do it uh US policy is
that this is a national security issue
it's very important to our
competitiveness maintaining a
technological Edge uh when talking about
that do you do you monitor uh
AI at all a little bit Yeah Yeah and
because you one of the things that I've
I've heard some people say is one of the
biggest um concerns sort of like we had
the space race with with the Russians
way back when uh I guess I'd call them
the Soviets to be more accurate um but
today it's AI the AI race with with
China do you see that also being the
case or how do you see it oh no we have
a space race again mhm okay we we're
racing an AI we're racing Quantum
Computing we're racing in
5G um we're racing on all kinds of
fronts right now with China and you know
the big complaint about China has always
been that they copy all of our stuff
that's what everybody says but the real
thing to be afraid of is that is when
China no longer copies us anymore and
they're out innovating us so we won the
space race and everything uh we
initially you know the Russians were
beating us at the beginning they they
had sput first and they had you know
Yuri gagaran the first man in space and
you know uh but we eventually were able
to put mount a serious effort that
Kennedy started you know we put some
people on the Moon by the end of the
decade we're trying to do that again
right uh I think 2024 is the next date
we'll see if we can do that but um yeah
I think on on multiple fronts uh we're
we're in a new Cold War I think people
are recognizing that now with China
which you know would presumably um spur
a lot more investment in just basic
research and development that will not
just stay in military matters it will
spill out into the the regular economy
at some point yeah because you we're
we're in a very different world with AI
and Quantum Computing I mean that's like
you know uh it could be scary if
somebody it'd almost be like the first
person to have a nuclear bomb right
saying H we've got this which means you
your security no longer exists if we got
a quantum computer you know kind of a
thing yeah so uh so I'd imagine that
hopefully there's there's a lot of act
activation of resources moving in that
direction yeah and I think a lot of
there's a lot of fear mongering with AI
I think like our own you know
intelligence is something so complex
it's so difficult to understand I don't
see machines getting anywhere near
anytime soon right I mean maybe not even
within our lifetimes to be quite honest
that doesn't mean it's it isn't a use
ful technology right yeah Quantum
Computing major major
concerns uh you know uncrackable
encryption at the same time a quantum
computer could presumably crack all of
our best codes rendering the internet as
we know it totally obsolete so there's
obvious reasons there why National
governments are racing on that uh but
could also be a big problem solver as as
AI can you know where you imagine if you
can actually accurately model the
Quantum behavior of molecules well with
a quantum computer presumably you could
do that better than with a classical
computer well now we could just design
from scratch uh brand new materials you
know yeah or new drugs or all kinds of
amazing things is it too early to invest
in companies working on this do you
think no it's not and there's there's a
lot of small companies that are private
right now that you can't touch but you
know major US companies IBM
Google um and there are others that are
working on
practical Quantum Computing so you know
right now we're probably at that stage
uh you know like with the early
electronic computers that were the size
of a building MH you know we're probably
somewhere in that stage right now in a
decade maybe uh we'll be like at the
Mainframe stage where it's something
major corporations use but it's not yet
penetrated into the American household
right and maybe in 20 30 years you know
you'll have a quantum computer in your
pocket you know so we'll see how that
goes but I do think it's it's going to
be a really big Trend here and it's
going to make a big splash by the end of
the decade AI is already making a a big
splash so it's already there you know
things are really kind of crazy
uncertain shifting changing you know the
the it's just a different world and it's
going to continue to be a different
world is this more exciting to you or
more scary to you you know how how's
your personal experience of all this
it's scary and it's exciting it's a
little bit of turbulence right uh bump
you ride I think there's a lot of
opportunity um you know I wouldn't bet
against our inventors or
innovators um that have kept our economy
flourishing for such a long time I don't
think that's going to go away um I think
if if we unleash that uh in the United
States I think um you know it's it's
going to create the next big booms in in
in our economy the next big
Transformations and technology and the
way we live the way we interact and
everything so definitely I'm I'm very uh
very bullish on our future despite
what's going on well that makes me feel
a whole lot better so thanks for sharing
that with us and Ray thanks for for you
know literally making the trip and
sitting down and and sharing all this
information I appreciate it always a
pleasure hello Patrick Tempo here with
probably the most unique bonus interview
we've shown you so far vision Yani is
the founder of mine Valley which is
dedicated to being the world's leading
personal growth platform Mine Valley
wasn't always 100 million doll company
and vision started it with just
$700 what was this wealth breakthrough
and how can you use it in your own life
tune in to find
[Music]
out
Vision thanks so much for spending some
time with us absolutely happy to be here
so let's start with your background your
story how did you become an entrepreneur
what got you into what you're doing
today so like all good entrepreneurs I
started with my first idea failing and
then my second idea failing then my
third idea failing and at this point the
failure was really brutal IID lost
around 30 grand I borrowed from my
father MH I was in Silicon Valley it was
the year of the bubble bursting 2000 or
so 2001 I believe and I I moved to
Silicon Valley with bold dreams as a
computer engineer to start a software
company based on an idea I had mhm I
didn't understand how tough it was going
to be I lost everything I was um only
able to afford renting a couch from a
Berkeley College student on that
two-seater couch was my entire life Wow
and so the economy was so bad I remember
April 2001 14,000 people were laid off
off in San Francisco right people were
attending ping slip parties and I had no
job prospects I had lost my business I
had lost a 30 grand from my father the
only job I could get was a Dialing for
Dollars job I had to pick up the phone
and persuade lawyers to buy technology
wow to help manage their law firms and
uh it was brutal it was depressing if
you've ever being a telemarketer
interrupting a busy Texas lawyer in the
middle of his workday
you are going to hear
more than what you'd ever expect so one
day after the N lawyer told me the off I
fell into a depression and I got on
Google and I decided to seek hope so I
searched for something I can't remember
what it was maybe it was why does life
suck so bad or it was why can't I be
happy and I found a class on meditation
MH so I flew to La I took that class and
I returned to my job the next day and
that class shifted something in me what
I know is that I started using abilities
of my mind that I never previously were
was was utilizing not the stuff that I
learned in school and in one week I
double my sales I continued going deeper
into these practices these Transcendent
practices this art of going within to
improve how you function in the world
and I double my sales again and again in
4 months I got promoted three times at
26 I Was Made director r
and now I was a key leader in this this
company they shipped me out to New York
I opened an office there I was 26 years
old I had men in their 40s reporting to
me and I learned a ton and 18 months
later I decided I wanted to start my own
business but this time I did it right I
had learned sales I had learned
marketing I wasn't just a software
engineer thinking that if you build it
they will come mhm I brought these ideas
into my next business Mine Valley and
it's been a freaking joy ride ever since
so where where did you grow up I grew up
in qual lumpo Malaysia so you grew up in
Malaysia and was your father in Malaysia
at the time you borrowed the money right
so uh you know after having a succession
of failures MH and you got yourself
turned around in the ways you described
what got you to say okay I'm ready to go
back and try again because that had to
be a very big decision right so so one
of the biggest things that I think we
have to go through in life right is
failure and how we approach failure
really depends on our world view but I
know that in studies of of Highly
Successful People one of the key
ingredient to their success is great
it's the ability to go through the road
bumps of life without making those bumps
rattle you to the point where you can't
continue and so I changed my world view
of failure I started seeing failure as
an opportunity to grow because from
every failure there's a seed of
knowledge that's going to be planted and
and this applies to failures across all
dimensions of Life someone dumps you it
freaking hurts but you learn what to do
correctly in your next relationship and
when a business fails it is so painful
but you learn what to do better in my
case I learned that I had needed to
master not just coding but marketing but
but sales for my next business idea to
take off so I started learning from
these failures and when I changed my
mindset to view failure as information
failure
is not a judgment failure is not is not
going to be a Perpetual stamp on your
brand failure is just information on
what doesn't work and you use that
information and you do what works and so
now I really approach failure with the
sense of like ease and joy going to fail
no problem I wonder what I'm going to
learn really interesting is uh how it
was just a change of mindset or or right
adopting mindfulness if you will was
that a part of your culture ever your
upbringing or was this the first time
that you discovered it you know what the
uh the style of meditation I first
picked up was
basically a meditation program that
originated on the Texas Mexican border
it it didn't come from India or China it
literally was started by a by a Texan
Mexican by the name of Jose Silva in the
60s he started a program called the
Silva mind control method and I guess
you can call it TexMex
meditation but but but true to American
style it wasn't about just going within
there's a grand my in meditation that
the point of meditation is to master
these inner states that's true yes
mastering your inner states for example
can help you ride through failure but
you are not going to truly live a great
life if you're only going within you got
to step out you got to be able to use
the lessons you learn from introspection
to go out in life and build and create
and change the world I call it the
difference between the Buddha and the
badass you need to reconcile both
the world doesn't just need badasses who
are going out there and crushing it at
the expense of their health and stress
and anxiety and broken families the
world also need Buddhas who can Master
the inner state but the world doesn't
need more Buddhas who are just going to
be meditating in a cave I mean get out
there and do something so I like to see
meditation and life as the point of
merging the Buddha and the badass so you
master the inner game but you use it to
actually go out and and do good at your
career at entrepreneurship at getting
that product or service out to market
the businesses that you started and
failed did any of them resemble what the
ideas of Mind Valley uh are or were they
completely different many of them were
completely different I started an early
version of Instagram in 2005 back then
it was bound for failure because proper
phones with cameras didn't really exist
I started a type of email software that
allowed you to take back an email you
know have you ever sent a drunk email
and you wish you could take it back it
allowed that it failed so there were
countless failures but I learned from
those failures and I learn what to do
that worked so how did the idea of Mind
Valley come about then so mind Valley
came about because taking that class on
meditation allowed me to just completely
excel at my job and I started asking
myself why is it that we don't learn
this stuff in school and that's when I
came across a quote by Mandela he said
if you want to change the world change
education mhm so I thought well this is
an interesting idea if I can create
something that can truly change the
world why not do it in education and
since I stumbled upon the education of
meditation and mindfulness let's focus
on that and that's how mind Valley
started the mind in mind Valley
literally comes from mind mindfulness
and so on was your father having any
conversations with you when you decided
to leave your job which you were doing
really good at and then uh to start M
Valley no at that point I was 26 that's
all I got to make my own decisions in
life so yeah so was he after you failed
with his money no but I remember what my
dad told me okay my dad said Vision okay
if you can't get to a level where you're
making at least 100 Grand a year you can
come work for me aha so he was like your
safety net he was my safety net yeah do
do you think he wanted you to fail so
you'd come work for him no okay he was
my dad see my dad the great thing about
my dad is I I I didn't grow up in a rich
family my my dad worked as a manager at
an department store my mom was a public
school teacher um like like growing up
it's not like we had a ton of money I
slept on a mattress next to my parents'
bed until I was 12 years old but then
when I was 13 my dad actually decided to
quit and become start his own business
and I learned from that I started
observing him and I decided that gosh I
want to be an entrepreneur I decided
when I was 14 or 15 that I would never
take a job that I would start my own
company so my mind was always obsessed
with this idea and even as I fail
because we all know it's hard it's not
easy even as I failed I kept pushing
through with the intent to someday be an
entrepreneur do you think now in
reflection and and working with so many
people that you work with in the world
do you think entrepreneurs are born do
you think that somebody can make the
decision it's not a hardwired thing that
they can become it uh how do you see it
well today I don't believe that we
should glorify entrepreneur right they
are sucky entrepreneurs and they are
great entrepreneurs they are sucky
employees and they are great employees
so that distinction is is not what I
what I care about what I care about is
are you doing something that you truly
love that pays the bills that allows you
to serve your purpose and that you're
really good at the Japanese have a name
for it it's called iy guy when you can
find your iy guy you find that that
sweet spot between what you really love
doing what you're good at what you were
born to do what you're using your your
natural skills for what makes you money
and what allows you to contribute to the
world that's The Sweet Spot you want to
go for now you can do that by starting
your own business you can do that by
finding a company that gives you room to
work in a role where you get those four
ingredients you don't have to be an
entrepreneur I mean if you think about
many of the people who were changing the
world they were not entrepreneurs but
they changed the world think about the
thousands of scientists at Nasa who
helped put a man on the moon right those
people they should be so proud of what
they did they were not entrepreneurs so
let's not over glorify entrepreneur now
at the same time you could be designing
logos on um Fiverr for five bucks you'd
be an entrepreneur the spectrum is just
too big it's interesting so the catch
all of entrepreneur or there really
needs to be I think Einstein said make
everything as simple as possible but not
simpler and it's maybe an
oversimplification it is it's a Ross
oversimplification so uh in terms of
having wealth breakthroughs uh what do
you think yours was was it finding
mindfulness what was the what was the
Breakthrough that got you from failure
to being working at a job to now a very
successful so business founder so I
think it was this right I believe I've
come to believe that your success at
entrepreneurship or at your career has
very little to do with your skills what
it rather has to do with is your beliefs
about the world we create a world around
us based on who we believe we are if we
believe that hard work is essential for
Success you will have to bust your back
to be successful if you believe that
money is hard to come by you're going to
work really you're going to be putting
in lots of hours to make money and it's
going to be tough if you believe that
business is difficult that being an
entrepreneur is difficult you're going
to face that our beliefs truly shape the
world we live in MH now the problem is
many of us don't know what we believe
right if you think about beliefs beliefs
are like icebergs there's a little bit
that's above the water right but there's
a lot that's underneath that we don't
know the beliefs that are underneath the
water the larger chunk of the iceberg
often those were beliefs programmed in
you when you were a child we don't know
that until some thing happens that
brings it out so in my first 5 years
building up a business we were doing
okay MH and then I became a father and
my son Hayden was 1 years old and I
decided I'm going to cut back working
just a little bit maybe an hour maybe 90
minutes a day so I could be a dad right
but I didn't realize that an insitu
little belief was in my head you see
when I was a teenager I remember my
father coming coming back from work one
day and um the doorbell rang my dad was
at the door he opened the door he walked
in my mom was in the kitchen cooking and
I was watching TV and I without looking
up the television I go hey Dad and dad
walks in and all of a sudden I hear a
loud crash and I turn around and my dad
has collapsed backwards on the floor
like boom he hit the ground my mom came
running out what was that and my dad was
lying on the ground we shook him awake
he had literally collapsed from
exhaustion W now I loved my father he
was my role model he's the reason I
became an entrepreneur so when I saw
that a belief entered my head and that
belief was to be an entrepreneur to be
successful you have to work hard and
it's going to cost you it's going to
cost your help it's going to make you
tired you're going to be coming back at
9:00 or 10 p.m. that was what I took on
so when I became an entrepreneur and I
became a father and I decided that I was
going to spend some time with my kid
that the leaf started taking place in
the back of of my head okay you're going
to cut back your working hours by 1 hour
no worries but you're not going to be
successful and that's when I one one
year after becoming a father I found
that the business was bleeding money and
if we didn't correct things in a few
months we were going to go out of
business we were making about a quarter
million a month which sounds like a lot
but we were losing 15,000 a month and
our bank balances were running really
really really low my business partner at
that time
had an MBA he was still in college that
right he he had a Stanford MBA owed a
ton of money to Stanford I didn't have
my own apartment I was living in a
bedroom in my parents' house I was
driving in Nissan March it was tough and
that's when I sank into a depression I'm
like what the is going on been doing
this for 5 years and it has to be this
uphill battle I've got a one-year-old
child now very often breakthroughs come
from breakdowns right and that was when
I decided to just go on a bit of a
journey I remember traveling to San
Diego to attend a seminar by um by a
philosopher by the name of Esther Hicks
I picked up some books by another
spiritual writer Neil Donald Walsh I
attended a seminar by har Becker the guy
who wrote the book the millionaire
mindset and as I started going through
all of this deep study in the works of
these spiritual philosophers I had an
Awakening and that Awakening
was I'm experiencing what I'm
experiencing in the world in relation to
money because my money beliefs were
messed M up i' taken on meanings about
money from observing my father from
observing my culture and I decided that
making money was hard that making money
required hard work that making money was
going to be a SLO that you got to make a
sacrifice you either work hard and I'm
not a good father or you become a good
father and see your business fail and
all of those beliefs were shaping my
world I started connecting the dots
between harer and Neil Donald Walsh and
Esther Hicks Neil Donald Walsh and his
book's conversation with god speak about
the idea that our beliefs create our
reality Hava speaks about how there are
no hard and fast rules about money
except what you believe to be true right
and and this Awakening shifted something
in me MH in 8 months as I came out of my
delusion in 8 months the business grew
400% we went from a quarter million a
month to a million a month in 8 months
flat and that transform my life but what
I learned from that was that making
money is easy hard work is a myth and
primarily the world that we experience
is a function of the beliefs in our head
reality doesn't exist we make it up so
there seems to be a pattern here because
when things are breaking down you seem
to have gone looking for Solutions and
usually outward like you know like the
first time going to La learning
meditation and is Silver mind control
this time you know right you're in this
predicament and you go and and you do
these different programs and reset your
your mindset uh so now if somebody's
watching us right now they're facing
challenges they're struggling what have
you um you what are do you have a a
methodology or technique to help uncover
what these beliefs might be absolutely
well uncovering beliefs can be tricky MH
okay they are there are two ways we
uncover beliefs my friend the Reverend
Michael bewit says that we grow through
Keno or we grow through t m Keno is
growth through pain right that's when
you end up in
hospital and through that painful
experience you understand how to take
better care of your health or in my case
your business is failing and through
that painful experience you reflect and
understand how you are operating through
a false lens as an entrepreneur that's
grow through pain can show moments but
we also grow through Satori sator is
grow through Insight now your soul and I
believe we all have a soul your soul is
designed to make you experience life in
the most beautiful way but most of us
are too stubborn to listen to our soul
when you learn to listen to the soul and
this is where meditation and
introspection come in you grow through
Satori your sator moments come to you
insights aha Revelations Awakenings but
when you're too stubborn to pause and
listen your soul will have to mesh up
and that's when the breaks happen that's
when the breakdowns that lead to the
breakthroughs so you have a choice we
all have a choice and you can choose Ken
show or you can choose Satori Satori is
a lot more pleasant now here's how you
choose Satori right firstly it's not
always going to be possible to meditate
and have a revelation and have this idea
download so there might still be Keno
moments every now and then but the more
you practice personal growth and
critical reflection and journaling and
Med meditation and reading books on
philosophy the more the satory moments
come the more the Awakenings come so
that's one thing
now that rule is one of the first
pillars I believe every entrepreneur
should adopt and that is make growth
your number one thing MH my other friend
SRI kumara who's one of the top MBA
professors in the world said you know
what the problem is with American
Business Schools they teach you that
your business is about your business ra
says that simply isn't true the only
thing that your life is about is growth
your soul is here to grow MH if your
business fails it doesn't matter did you
grow if your business becomes a billion
dollars it doesn't matter did you grow
the only thing that matters that growth
growth has to be your number one goal
mhm now when you Embrace that a couple
of interesting things happen firstly you
will actively go out and seek sator
moments true reading true classes true
meditation that was what I was doing
when I learned my techmech style of
when I attended seminars by harer and
and and uh and Esther Hicks right I was
seeking Satori that's a really important
role I made growth number one and I grew
out of my pain so that's the first thing
make growth your number one thing and if
you as an entrepreneur do that the money
will come as you grow everything around
your life grows your relationship with
your kids the money your business
everything grows but you need a second
rule because remember there might still
be pain as much as you're growing there
might still be things you're unconscious
of and life might come and hit you now
the second rule is this Embrace pain mhm
Canal moments are not bad what if all
pain is nothing more than a soul simply
moving Us in the right direction and
sometimes to move you in the right
direction someone has to smack you at
the back of your head and what if pain
is nothing more than that so what I mean
by embracing pain is to remember this
the Afghan poet roomi said oh ye who
cannot take a good rub how will you ever
become a polished gem mhm the Embrace of
pain is a beautiful belief system to
adopt when you go to a gym and you work
out and you come out there and you can
barely walk you're growing yourself
through pain right but we are trained to
believe that failure that pain is wrong
or shameful so let me give you some
classic examples you fail at a
you feel like a failure but what if you
change that mindset what if you simply
go oh this is nothing more than
information going to learn from this and
bounce back you fail at a relationship
or you go through a divorce you're
labeled a failure that's
stupid what if you see that as simply a
way to grow yourself to understand what
you truly want in a life partner so when
you view pain from a different lens
without shame without guilt Without
Blame pain becomes information now you
can apply this as an entrepreneur one
one of the companies I've I've studied
and company that I really love in terms
of how they operate is Google and Larry
Page the founder of Google has a very
interesting philosophy it's called the
50/50 rule so Google operates all their
teams set objectives and key results
right it's classic goal setting
mechanism but one of the interesting
things that Larry Pig introduced and I
brought this into my company is the
50/50 rule 50% of your goals must have a
50% chance of failure therefore every
Department in Google must have 50% of
their goals as basically a coin flip a
50% chance of failure now Google
actually fails at 40% of everything they
do according to Steven lit's book in the
Plex I mean remember Google Buzz failure
Google Glass failure but Google also
gave us Gmail it gave us YouTube it gave
us AdWords it's had incredible successes
but failure at Google is simply seen as
information no guilt no shame no
judgment now you can apply the same
principle in your life today when I said
set goals I make sure that 50% of my
goals have a 50% chance of failure now
when you think about this you actually
only want to be accomplishing not 100%
of your goals cuz that means you're
thinking too small but accomplishing 60
to 80% of your goals because you must
create room for failure and this pushes
you to be bold it pushes you to dream
big but it also pushes you to not fall
into the traps or feeling guilty or
feeling sh ashamed when failure which is
inevitable strikes now when you take
those two mindsets and you bring them
into your core you operate in the world
in a completely different sense well
what's interesting is uh you're talking
about risk you know and uh sometimes
maybe people think that risk is is a bad
thing or they become risk adverse but
probably the driving emotion that would
prevent somebody from doing it where
what you're describing is associating
shame with the failure right and nobody
wants to feel shame right and then they
get then they play small because they
they want to be safe so uh at what point
do you feel like you started taking
risks on a consistent basis and what
kind what kinds of things did you learn
from it so one of the first things I do
and I do this across my entire company
right now close to 300 people every
department has their list of objectives
and key results all the key results are
perfectly measurable so you know if
you've hit it or not for example our app
division might say grow the number of
people on our app every single hour from
say 15,000 to 22,000 by this state and
sometimes the goals that they set are
ridiculously high we don't even know how
we're going to achieve them but we set
them anyway because of the 50/50 rule so
it creates a different style of running
an organization where people can dare to
be bold and where if you fail there is
no judgment It's Perfectly Normal and it
allows me as the founder to also place
bets where I might fail that's perfectly
okay the removing of that shame and
judgment is essential to creating
Innovation and to allowing your mind to
really expand by giving them permission
to fail uh does do sometimes they lose
motivation then saying oh well you know
I'm expected not to make you know a
certain amount of these goals anyway uh
is there some kind of a carrot you offer
if they happen to hit it that that gets
them to want to strive for it a little
bit actually what I believe is that
human beings are naturally gold driven
organisms right the attainment of the
goal itself is huge for people and when
you are the right people they're going
to be gold driven so there are no
carrots you don't want carrots you want
people to pursue the goal for the sake
of knowing that they pursued that goal
because getting there meant something
nobody climbs Mount Everest for a
certificate they're climbing Mount
Everest because accomplishing the goal
builds up on their identity it makes
them a different person it's a natural
sense to evolve as an organism when we
achieve something the harder it is the
more it gives us Pride honor the more it
makes us believe in ourselves we change
from attaining these goals so you've got
all these learnings now how long has
mind Valley been out there mind Valley
in sense of the business model that we
have right now since 2013 okay so it's
been out there roughly six years right
okay and uh your trajectory is really
strong right now you're building a big
Community um at what point did you start
recognizing that uh putting or creating
a brand from this business that is
public facing that you know sort of
defined you uh becomes important well I
didn't really think of it as a brand
until I started realizing that there
were certain things in the world that I
cared about that I really wanted to use
my business as a Force for good to stand
behind right you have said this your
stand is your brand I wasn't even
thinking about branding but I was
obsessed about certain stands in the
world standing up for the environment
standing up for Unity in politics and I
decided to add that to my education
brand and it was really interesting
because we lost a couple of our
followers but the company expanded and
grew exponentially and this is an
interesting thing then cuz I don't want
to go over that too fast it's uh you
talk about a wealth breakthrough uh for
you uh when you took a stand it
alienated you know some part of your
audience but at you simultaneously grew
pretty quickly I think right when that
happened so what's the phenomena why
would that be I believe that well recent
studies show that 75% of American
consumers want CEOs and Brands to stand
for something so people are now
demanding more accountability in CEOs in
companies we got to take a stand for the
environment we got to take a stand for
Unity and not division in politics so
this is really about leadership whether
it be in a home in a business in
politics
uh the same rules apply across the board
mhm so when you start having some of
these realizations did it impact you
also as a father absolutely so my
daughter's name is Eve Eve is four years
old and
um all the business decisions I set I
asked myself a question that I call the
Eve
question so 20 years from now when Eve
graduates
College will the actions of my products
and my services make the world better
off for Eve or worse off are the
products and services that I'm releasing
based on creating consumer demand you
know like Coca-Cola high fructose corrup
manufactured as happiness in a red can
is it something that's D destroying the
environment it's it is it something
that's helping nationalism arise on the
planet or is it something that's
creating a better Synergy between human
beings and the ecology something that's
contributing to human health and
education so I try to make the world a
better place now one of the guidelines I
look at is the UN the United Nations
sustainable development goals the UN
looks looked at around 20 to 25 goals
that they say that all countries and all
businesses should be looking at this
these are goals that allow us to create
a better world it includes better
education it includes clean water so all
my businesses must align with the UN
sustainable development goals
interesting so one time when I was
interviewing John Mackey the uh the
co-founder and CEO of Whole Foods I
asked him you know what kind of Legacy
do you want to leave and he said I don't
think it go kind of egotistical to think
about leaving a Legacy isn't it but
you're talking about leaving a legacy so
do you have a sense of like you know
here's the Legacy that I want my uh
actions and creativity in my life
absolutely go ahead what is that yeah so
what I want to do is I want to create
the greatest education system Humanity
has ever had because a lot of the
problems we're facing in the world today
come down to a broken education system
the reason obesity and diabetes are on
the rise is because our education system
doesn't teach us how to eat healthy
let's let's go deeper education teaches
you biology they don't teach you how to
live in a healthy body your education
might make you memorize facts of history
and geography they don't teach you how
to truly be creative how to thrive at a
job how to start your own business you
might learn economics you don't learn
how to get rich you don't learn how to
create a better world you learn how to
be safe so you can get a decent job but
you don't learn how to become a job
Creator mhm education prepares you for
very little in life in terms of what
matters and today if you have a
smartphone which almost everyone does
you have access to more information than
the president of the United States had
in
1995 yet we still train our brains for
the world of the 1980s and 1990s so what
I'm seeking to do is to to completely
transform education globally mind Valley
is my vehicle and we focus on creating
the best learning platform the best
teachers the best curriculum design and
most importantly the education that
truly matters how to make human beings
Thrive as a human being it sounds like
you're making a distinction between
academics and education right like Mark
twin said right never let School get in
the way of your education right exactly
cuz you're describing in Academia
you know it doesn't really resemble the
real world in any kind of a practical
way so you're talking about making
education practical right to be able to
put it on the ground and that's what
mind valle's really what its thrust is
right so in doing that um how do you
translate that into your internal
culture as far as the the employees you
say you have 300 employees roughly right
now and so how how do you translate that
so that they get that and they're all
kind of all the everybody's pulling the
Chariots in the same direction so
firstly we practice what we preach right
right the people at M Valley we do our
own programs I do our own programs um
for example one of our top programs is
Life Book which you had a role in in
creating everyone at mind Valley as soon
as you join the company within month one
you go for a retreat to the mountains
you spend 4 days in deep immersion
creating a book of your life a 75-page
document of how you want your entire
life to unfold in all the categories of
Being Human and at the end of that you
can take that and decide you know
working at mind value will help me get
there so I'm going to stay or you can
say you know I think I'll go leave and
start my own business and that's okay
right so everyone in our company starts
with a Clear Vision for their life now
it goes further then because we have
incredible programs in health and
fitness such as wildfit we have um
programs on muscle building programs on
meditation people go into these
different streams and they Master what
they want to master so as I've been
leading this company between now and
2016 I've actually gotten healthier on
almost every Health metric I've put on
more muscle I've lost around 14 I've
gotten way fitter and so have everyone
who works for me there's a joke at mind
valy that in your first year you will
lose anywhere from 10 to
20 so uh so you create that in the
culture they start to all line up with
that now I know and you have a lot of uh
younger people in your audience are kind
of starting out or embarking right now
okay you've got the experience of
failure you got the experience of
success you've thought about these
things a lot um you also have the
benefit of relationships with some very
influential people um now they're coming
to you saying Hey I want to go and make
my mark on the world I want my wealth
break through I want to be able to uh
you know to do something great that I'm
passionate about that I'm properly
rewarded for where do I start what would
you advise them well I think the first
thing
is is understand that school trains you
for for a tiny Slice of Life it says
that what truly matters is your career
and the money you have in your bank
account that's not true right we V
familiar with the Life Book methodology
John Butcher our mutual friend talks
about looking at life from 12 different
dimensions including dimensions of
character emotional states intellectual
life and I know you actually helped
create life book yeah well we were the
first experiment you John John life book
was John's own personal thing and then
he taught it to us and we gave him
feedback on on the whole process and
that's how it became a business and and
you even helped come up with the 12th
category intellectual life yeah
intellect well intellectual life was
very important for me so my wife Lori
and I were you know we would look at the
things that we were interested in and
that was a part of the feedback we gave
you yeah so one of the first things I'd
encourage people to do is to go so life
book is now run by mind Valley John is a
dear mutual friend of ours one of the
first things I advise people to go is to
go to life. valley.com and take the free
lifebook assessment and it'll shine a
light on how to look at your life from
these 12 dimensions and understand where
you might be falling short and where you
might be thriving see the classic
mistake people make is that if you're in
a job you want to specialize if you're a
graphic designer and you want to really
improve your hourly rate you don't go
and suddenly Master coding you stay at
graphic design and you become a master
of graphic design that's how your income
goes up but at life you don't specialize
you need to be well-rounded I mean you
could be making tons of money but if
your health is bad that's really going
to mess up the quality of your life you
could have incredible relationships but
if you're broke those relationships are
going to go through some hardship so you
want to create a well-balanced life now
when you take the Life Book assessment
you start going through a form of
critical reflection it takes around 22
minutes and you come up with a picture
of where in life you are thriving and
where you need to improve Now by knowing
where you need to improve you now know
the right books the right teacher the
right programs to take so that you can
create balance in your life one of the
takeways I'd say so far is that you know
wealth and developing wealth is uh you
that it starts with asking the question
of who to be right as compared to here's
what you need to do uh with that now
you've been at this for a while you've
practiced mindfulness you've gone
through you know your your failures you
you've got your success the momentum
everything you're doing right now um how
much does continued self-discovery play
in in your current life are you still
trying to dig up blind spots are you
still trying to find out what's below
the surface in that Iceberg AB of course
you can never stop at self-improvement
right and it's the most important thing
to fuel your life now I believe that
everyone should spend an hour a day
dedicated to their own self- Evolution I
call this your rate of self-evolution
your rose so how fast are you growing
your rose your rate of self-evolution so
every single day I start my day with
meditation I go on to optimized exercise
I go on to a nutrition which might be
supplements it might be intimate and
fasting it might be making myself a
healthy Shake I might do some journaling
I might do a gratitude practice I listen
to podcasts or mind Valley programs on
my way to work all of that takes an hour
but every single day I'm becoming a
better human being I believe all of us
should grow so fast that our friends
whom we haven't met in a month have to
get to know us all over again so so
burning down your identity and kind of
uh emerging something new from that is
an ongoing process for you so when you
are going through these realizations and
changes like you do uh do you find it
destabilizing when you're going through
some of these identity shifts or changes
like where you might have do you have a
period where you feel a little bit lost
or is it pretty smooth Road it's pretty
smooth once you get into the practice of
personal growth it's a gentle upward
ride knowing a little bit about you and
knowing that you practice what you
preach uh you don't have your employees
start work till I think you said 11:00
right uh so 10:30 11 so they can get up
in the morning and also have all these
practices before they begin their work
ex it's called there's a word for that
it's called morning autonomy it's giving
people freedom to own their mornings so
they can utilize their mornings to spend
time with their spouse or to work out at
the gym or to meditate or to read a book
it actually creates happier better
employees does that shift go later into
T night or what time are they done
typically people choose we don't have
set working hours you finish your work
early go home early well I think uh
that's about as great a sentiment as we
can possibly end on so uh really
appreciate you sharing your experience
your wisdom and your thoughts with us
thank you to see the next episode in the
wealth breakthrough series check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there whether they're
investing in real estate business stocks
or Commodities learning how to short can
be a very intelligent thing it's not
about real estate it's about the dollar